Hallo, hallo. Was ist hier los? Ah, mein Vorschau-Computer backt rum. Nice. Excellent. So, Chat, wir
müssen mal gucken, ob das von der Bitrate her passt. Ich hab das mal auf der Default-Bitrate
gelassen, weil das Game ist ja nun nicht sonderlich, ja, 240 FPS aufwärts. Ich schau
mal kurz, wie das Ganze aussieht. Joa, sieht doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus. Kann man
eigentlich nichts sagen. Sieht echt okay aus. Wird da raus? Dankeschön für den Sub. Hey
Leute, ich hab jetzt noch ungefähr zwei Stunden Zeit und ich hab mir gedacht, weißt was, bevor
ich alleine weiter Ball losgehe, spiele ich einfach im Stream ein bisschen. Ich bin nicht
mehr am Anfang, aber ich glaube, nur mal so am Anfang angemerkt, ich glaube, es hält
sich spoilertechnisch jetzt das, was wir jetzt spielen, echt stark in Grenzen, ja.
Wir machen ein paar Sidequests und also ich hab nicht vor, irgendwie jetzt Akte zu wechseln
oder irgendwelche Main-Story-Quests oder sowas zu machen, zwei Stunden lang. Aber ich meine,
ich hab ja auch noch genug zu tun, wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt. Ist ja noch ein bisschen
was. Wobei, so viel ist nicht mehr. Also, ich kenn die Karte so grob noch. Ich weiß,
die Karte, ich glaube, hier unten geht's noch ein bisschen weiter. So im Großen und Ganzen ist es
aber schon mehr oder weniger Akt 1 fertig. Ich hab noch das komplette Underdark übrig und ich
hab noch, ja, hier oben noch ein paar Quests. Und hier unten noch, die hier. Ja, da machen wir jetzt
was. Also wie gesagt, storytechnisch gibt's keine großartigen Spoiler. Ich hab mir gedacht,
ich mach jetzt einfach noch mal zwei Stunden bisschen Sidequests. Bisschen looten, bisschen
Items sammeln. Ich spiel übrigens, für den Fall der Fälle, dass das aufkommt, ich hab übrigens
extra für euch das Game auf Deutsch umgestellt. Gerade eben. Geht ziemlich schnell in Steam.
Musst auch nicht das komplette Game runterladen. Ich hatte ja schon Spiele, die mussten komplett
runtergeladen werden, nur weil du irgendwie die Sprache geändert hast. Das ist glücklicherweise
nicht so. Aber die Texte sind auf Deutsch, aber die Sprache ist weit auf Englisch. Also wird's
nicht ganz so schlimm. Ja, Schwierigkeitsgrad ist das hier. Es ist das Höchste, was es gibt,
aber es ist trotzdem wirklich nicht schwer, das Game. Das muss man echt sagen. Also das Game ist
nicht schwer. Zumal man gefühlt jeden Fight irgendwie cheasen kann. Und dadurch, dass das
jeden Fight geht, kannst du irgendwas machen, ja? Fässer hinstellen, dich irgendwo positionieren,
wo die Gegner nicht hinkommen oder sowas. Das ist eigentlich eher schon Design als Cheese, ja.
So, ich spiel hier in Kombination Pfeiffer. Ja, High IQ Wizard only. Also als Party hab ich am
Start Will. Also mein Main Character ist Gale, weil ganz im Ernst, ich versteh nicht, wie Leute
es schaffen, ohne Wizard und Cleric zu spielen. Keine Ahnung. Ich mein, du kannst bestimmt mit
dem Druide spielen, aber Cleric ist irgendwie must have. Im Prinzip ist Wizard und Cleric eh must
have. Das heißt, eigentlich bleibt nicht so viel übrig. Einen Frontline-Charakter brauchst du,
kommst nicht drumherum. Es gibt theoretisch noch einen Parler. Das ist aber eher sowas,
wie gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht so alles Mögliche spoilern, aber der Parler ist eher
was für ein zweites Playthrough, den es gibt. Und als Tank gibt es ja nicht so viel, außer die hier,
wo ich mir nicht merken kann, wie man die ausspricht. Also im Prinzip ist nur der
vierte Slot wirklich variabel und das ist bei mir Will. Da kann man aber eigentlich alle spielen.
Solange man Frontline-Cleric-Wizard hat, der Rest ist eigentlich wurscht. Ich warte mal kurz,
bis das Stream richtig angelaufen ist. Wie gesagt, wir machen nur ein paar Sidequests.
Ja, wenn ihr wollt, ich kann es auch wieder auf Englisch zurückstellen, aber ich dachte mir so,
viele fragen immer so bei Games so nach dem, oh Max, kannst du auf Deutsch,
ich stelle es jetzt mal auf Deutsch. Die Sprache ist aber, guckt hier, die Sprache ist immer noch,
well, das ist der Hearthstone-Kurs, well met. Dein Sumpf schaut so schön aus. Ja,
das ist bis jetzt das netteste Gebiet, finde ich. Das hier, also rein optisch,
ist das bisher so, dass das noch das netteste Gebiet. Der Sumpf ist nicht so schön. Ja,
ich vermute ja auch, dass wenn man, dass der Sumpf irgendwann sumpfig aussieht. Ich glaube,
das habe ich sogar schon auf dem Screenshot irgendwo gesehen. Guck mal, da ist ein Schaf.
Pass mal auf, Will ist übelst pfeiffert, der kann speak with animals. Wir müssen mal kurz mit dem
Schaf gehen. Mal gucken, was das Schaf sagt. Moin Schaf, was geht? Ach so, mehr können die nicht
sagen. Jetzt habe ich extra schon speak with animals oder wie es auf Deutsch heißt, Anrufung
mit Tieren sprechen und die sagen nicht mal was. Ja, stellst du hier mal ein bisschen rum. Ja,
wie gesagt, also meine Party-Composition, Cleric, Wizard, Fighter, Warlock. Finde ich eigentlich
ganz gut bisher. Ich habe schon mehr oder weniger fast alles gemacht, was es im ersten Akt gibt.
Warum ist da ein Imp in meiner Party? Weil Will ein, sieht man das genau? Charaktereigenschaften
so hier, gell? Weil Will ein, ne das meine ich nicht, der Unhold. Will ist, wo steht es denn? Was
ich für eine Spezialisierung genommen habe? Steht das hier gar nicht oder sehe ich es jetzt irgendwie
nicht? Oder ist es der, ne, keine Ahnung. Ich habe diesen Packed-Off-Chain genommen. Da kriegt man
ein Pet zum Beschwören, wobei ich sagen muss, das Pet ist gar nicht mal so geil. Ich meine,
das Pet hat zehn Lebenspunkte, ist aber immun gegen Feuer und alles. Ist immun gegen Feuer,
kann sich unsichtbar machen, aber was das Beste ist an dem Viech ist, also man kann es beliebig
oft, beliebig oft beschwören, aber das Beste an dem Viech ist, das hat eine übelste Reichweite
und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das in Baldur's Gate ordentlich implementiert ist, aber normaler
Weise können Range-Caster und Range-Bogenschützen und sowas können nur mit Disadvantage angreifen,
wenn ein Nahkampf-Charakter neben ihnen steht. Das heißt, dafür ist das Ding richtig gut. Wenn
du irgendwelche Fernkämpfer hast und du stellst deinen Imp daneben, dann müssen die erstmal deinen
Imp killen oder wegrennen, wo der Imp noch ein bisschen Damage drauf machen kann, dass die dich
überhaupt hitten können. Ich bin mir generell über Baldur's Gate 3 immer nicht ganz sicher,
was alles von den 5 E-Regeln... Schaf! Was geht mit dir ab, Alter? Warum ist das Schaf gerade einmal
quer über den Bildschirm gejumpt? Was auch immer. Ich bin mir bei dem Game eh nicht so 100% sicher,
was alles von den 5 E-Regeln implementiert ist und was... Oh, da hinten ist noch ein Schaf. Reden
wir mal mit dem Schaf. Reden wir erstmal mit dem Schaf. Irgendeines von diesen Schafen muss
doch was sagen können. Ne, die sagen alle nichts. Obwohl ich Anrufungen mit Tieren sprechen habe.
Ne, die Schafe haben keinen Bock. Die wollen nicht. Ich bin mir bei dem Game eh nicht so ganz sicher,
was alles von den 5 E-Regeln implementiert ist. Manches Advantage, Disadvantage ist nicht dabei.
Diese ganze Highground-Attacker-Sache gibt es ja so in der Art und Weise auch nicht. Ich habe mir ein
paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, aber letztendlich... Oh, was haben wir denn hier? Aber letztendlich ist
es auch egal, weil es ist ein Game und es ist keine Pen-and-Paper-Session. Finde ich nicht
wirklich wild. So ein paar Sachen... Oh, Moment. Vodafone? Vodafone? Vodafone? Was ist hier los?
Dropframes? Vodafone? Hallo? Was geht da ab? Ja, ja, Highground gibt es für Fernkämpfer,
aber es gibt normalerweise keine Highground-Regelung. Also es ist komplett offen. Also eigentlich gibt
es keinen Advantage mit Highground. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen, aber wie gesagt,
letztendlich muss man sich da gar nicht so viel Gedanken machen, denke ich. Denn ihr habt mich
falsch verstanden. Ich meine nicht im Game Highground. Es gibt eigentlich in der Vorlage
keine Highground-Regelung. Das hat das Game dazu gedichtet. Was ich aber gar nicht so übel finde.
War hier nicht eine Falle gerade? Erstmal safe scannen, falls es nicht funktioniert.
Da kommt 10, das müsste easy klappen. Und wie geht es denn hier lang? Hier kann man weiter.
Da muss ich mal kurz gucken, was da oben ist. Ja, ich habe mir ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben. Also
es gibt eigentlich nur eine Sache, die mir im Kampfsystem wirklich fehlt. Und zwar, normalerweise
ist das so, ich versuche euch das mal kurz zu demonstrieren. So, wenn man einen rundenbasierten
Modus anmacht. Je nach Initiativreihenfolge, man sieht es wahrscheinlich auch gleich,
wenn es wirklich einen richtigen Fight gibt. Nach Initiativreihenfolge kann es ja durchaus sein,
dass jetzt nicht der Charakter drankommt zuerst, den man gerne hätte. So, und normalerweise,
und das gibt es in Baldur's Gate 3 nicht, das ist aber wirklich das Einzige, wo ich jetzt sagen
würde, hey, das fehlt mir richtig. So aus dem eigentlichen Regelwerk. Der Rest ist,
ich nenne es mal kreative Freiheit. Es gibt ja auch in dem Game total viel, was es so nicht
gibt. Von irgendwelchen werfbaren Bomben und alles mögliche. Oder keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Ob es
das nicht doch irgendwo gibt. Aber es gibt eine Sache, die mir wirklich fehlt und das ist Ready
Action. Weil, es kann sein, wobei, wir rennen jetzt mal rum und beim nächsten Kampf versuche
ich euch das zu erklären, was ich meine. Haben wir hier irgendwas? Habe ich eigentlich alle
Spells ready? Lass mal gucken. Ja, alles ready, alles ready, alles ready, okay. Bin quasi voll
gerestet. Aha, guck mal, hier geht es weiter. Aber bestimmt rüberspringen. Easy. Generell,
ich müsste eigentlich nirgendwo rüberspringen, weil ich mittlerweile einfach fliegen als Spell
habe. Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten? Übrigens, bei den Items verclicke ich mich immer regelmäßig.
Was mich immer übelst verwirrt, wo ich mich auch schon ein paar mal selbst gekillt habe,
ist, du hast ja normalerweise, hast du hier mit Gale, hast du halt den Feuerball, also den
Feuerball-Cantrip, den man so oft casten kann, wie man will. So, und mit Will habe ich das nicht.
Dafür habe ich Eldricks Pla... Okay, sorry. Schauriger Strahl habe ich mit Will. Und ich
klicke oftmals, weil ich denke, ich habe Gale angedrückt, drücke ich auf Burning Hands und
dann habe ich schon ein paar mal selbst abgefackelt. Weil, ich meine, es ist halt auch noch
ausgerechnet irgendwie so fast, fast am gleichen Spot und sieht auf den ersten Blick auch noch
fast gleich aus. Kurz stelzen, da ist was. Uralter Schlamm. Was haben wir denn hier am Start? Level
4, Level 3. Okay, die können gar nichts, die Viecher. Was ist das? Ups. Können nix. Haben wir
hier noch was? Das ist alles. Easy. Dann buffen wir uns mal schnell. Muss mich jetzt echt rein
gewöhnen, dass die Dinger auf Deutsch heißen. Da finde ich wahrscheinlich nix. So, eine Runde
Bless. Bless für mich, Bless für dich, Bless für dich. Ich habe mich verklickt. Egal. Und jetzt kann
ich euch gleich zeigen, was ich meine mit Ready Action. So, eine Runde Bless. So, Shadowheart,
du kannst mal hierhin stelzen auf den Felsen. Will geht jetzt her und Eldricks blastet den Dude.
Gail kann da stehen bleiben und mein Fighter geht schon mal ein bisschen vor, dass wir ordentlich,
dass wir ordentlich attacken können. So, Will basht ihn jetzt weg. Passt auf. Easy win. Suck
that. Wait. Moment. Ich habe ja immer noch Turn-Based an. Ich habe mich schon gerade
gewundert. Wie? Warum reagieren die nicht? Warte mal, ich mache mal Turn-Based aus. Jetzt
sollten es die Gegner eigentlich checken. Nein, nein, nein. Du sollst vor. Was machst du denn?
Du sollst dahin. Okay, ja, wenn ihr mir schon so entgegenkommt, wenn ihr mir schon so entgegenkommt,
dann gibt es jetzt einmal eine Runde Fireball in your face. Danach muss ich eh resten. Okay,
jetzt haben sie es aber gecheckt, dass ich da bin. So, jetzt ist das, was ich euch eigentlich zeigen
wollte. So, wenn so ein Kampf anfängt, also das ist die einzige Mechanic, die ich wirklich so aus
der 5e-Vorlage vermisse, die dem Kampfsystem, finde ich, recht gut getan hätte. So, jetzt hast
du ja am Anfang von einem Fight wird ja Initiative gewürfelt, also sprich in welcher Reihenfolge die
Gegner und man selbst rankommt. Passt eigentlich die Lautstärke und sowas vom Game? Müsste,
müsste passen, denke ich. Es wird ja am Anfang Initiative gewürfelt und mal angenommen, mal
angenommen, es kommt jetzt irgendein Charakter dran, zum Beispiel Gale oder, oder ja, nehmen wir
mal Gale. Der kommt jetzt dran, aber ich will eigentlich zuerst mit meinem Fighter draufhauen.
Dann kannst du jetzt eigentlich nichts machen. Du kannst irgendwas casten oder irgendwas oder
dich weiter wohin stellen. Du kannst mit Gale diesen Turn nichts machen, wenn es nicht explizit
was gibt, was du machen willst. Normalerweise kannst du, leider und das ist wirklich das einzige,
was ich schade finde, dass sie das nicht implementiert haben. Normalerweise kannst du
sagen Ready Action, also du kannst dir irgendeinen Spell, also einer von den, von den, von den Cantrip
Spells kannst du dir aussuchen, den als Ready Action für diese Runde eintragen und sobald ein Gegner
in deine Reichweite kommt, wird auch wenn du jetzt nicht am Zuge bist, wird dieser Spell dann ausgelöst.
Das ist so ein bisschen Overwatch Mechanic, wie man es aus anderen Games vielleicht kennt. Das
haben sie in Baldur's Gate 3 nicht drin. Das ist wirklich was, was ich denke, das hätte den Kämpfen
noch mal ein bisschen mehr taktische Tiefe gegeben. Das finde ich schade, dass das nicht drin ist.
Wait a minute, ich kann euch jetzt noch mal Fireball blasten? Na gut, easy. Ich blaste hier noch mal
Fireball. Wie? Was jetzt? Gale, was ist mit dir los? Drauf. Ist wahrscheinlich zu kompliziert zu
verstehen oder wegen den Träger. Vielleicht auf der anderen Seite, du kannst es einfach triggern
lassen, wenn ein Gegner in Reichweite von deinem Spell oder in Reichweite von, von deinem, von
deiner Ready Action kommt. Das finde ich ein bisschen schade, dass Ready Action nicht drin ist. Okay, die
klingen echt heftig auf den Sack. So, Gale ist fertig. Gale könnte, Gale könnte noch abhauen. Ich werde
danach eh Long Rest machen, bevor ich zur Hexe gehe. Also jetzt kann ich auch so alles an Zaubern
eigentlich raushauen, was ich will, aber Gale kann auch einfach hier stehenbleiben. So, der fliegt jetzt
hier hin und haut einmal drauf. Ja, stimmt, du hast, du hast recht, aber ich meine, man muss es ja
nicht übertreiben. Ja, zumal es, zumal es durch, genau, es gibt ja durchaus Reaction. Ja, es gibt ja, es
gibt ja durchaus Reaction, wie soll man sagen, Reaction Actions. Zum Beispiel, wenn du, wenn du, wie heißt
es, Schild, wenn du den Schildzauber hast, den kannst du ja auswählen, wenn Gegner dich treffen. Kriegst
dann so ein Fenster aufgeploppt, möchtest du jetzt nicht Schild einsetzen. Wenn wir Glück haben,
killt er das Viech jetzt. Ne, der kann das Viech nicht killen. Der macht ein komplettes Gegenteil von
das Viech killen. Spurten. Oh, da sind ja noch mehr. Ich dachte schon, easy as fuck fight, aber ist es
gar nicht. Ja, aber, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch? Die Viecher können ja wirklich nix. Ich glaube,
wird trotzdem easy. So, das, das Viech machen wir jetzt platt und bei den anderen müssen wir mal
gucken. Will hat auch noch Fireball am Start. Wir sollten den killen, wenn es hittet. Nice. Weg. Komm,
ich muss danach, ich muss danach eh zum Lager. Ich kann jetzt einfach alles rauskloppen an Spells,
was es gibt. Mein Zug. Ich glaube, ich, ich glaube, ich sehe die nicht. Guck, jetzt ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Jetzt ist ein gutes Beispiel, für warum es schade ist, dass es keine Ready Action gibt. So, ich könnte,
jawohl, ist gut. Ich könnte jetzt normalerweise sagen, Will, ich kann nichts machen in die Runde,
ja. Wobei, naja, gut, ich könnte jetzt Misty Step dahin machen und trotzdem casten. Aber angenommen,
ich könnte jetzt nichts machen in die Runde, dann könnte ich jetzt sagen, normalerweise Ready Action,
Eldricks Blast. So, und sobald so ein Viech hier um die Ecke kommt, obwohl Will nicht dran ist,
könnte er den wegblasten. Könnte jetzt eine Runde Misty Step hier oben hin machen und dann noch auf
die Gegner, wo wir am besten hingehen. Ich will die Kiste nicht treffen. Ach ja, und das ist auch
so ein Ding, was ich beispielsweise in, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welches Game das war. Pillars of
Eternity war das, glaube ich. Was ich in Pillars of Eternity sehr nice fand, für IE Spells, also
Zauber, die so einen gewissen Gebiet, Gebiet Damage machen. Man kann die hier nicht, oder ich
habe den Button noch nicht gefunden. Vielleicht habt ihr ja einen Plan davon. Man kann die nicht
aimen richtig, ohne dass die so, ihr seht es, dass die so Auto locken auf was. Das ist richtig
nervig. Manchmal willst du nämlich den Fireball hier irgendwie drei Meter oben über die in die
Luft machen. Das geht, soweit ich weiß, in Baldur's Gate nicht. Guckt mal, das Viech, also die Waffe
kann man nicht treffen, aber guckt mal. Stellt euch mal vor, ich will hier hinten hin, hier hinten
hin. Das ist teilweise übelst schwierig, drauf zu aimen, wenn man kein so freies, freies Aim hat
mit dem, mit der Area. Deadge. Ja, ich würde sagen, wo sind denn überhaupt noch Gegner?
Chat? Ach, da hinten. Ich wollte gerade sagen, hab überhaupt nicht gesehen, das Vieh. Kommt man da
vielleicht dran, von hier? Ja, natürlich nicht. Das ist jetzt wieder was, wo die Action gut gewesen
wäre. Was ist hier? Aha, der beschwört was. Mit Doppelklick auf das Padre. Ja, ich habe den
gar nicht gesehen, eben oben in der Leiste. Will Glück haben? So weit kommen wir nicht. Ich denke
nicht, dass wir da hinkommen. Oh, doch. Nice. Nice Aim. Die kenne ich, die kenne ich. Ja, ja. Wobei
ich die eigentlich so gut wie nie benutze, ehrlich gesagt, die Draufsicht. Ah, Mist. Kann ja
ein bisschen laufen. Na gut, da musst du jetzt dran glauben. Ja, ich mag die Draufsicht auch nicht.
Ich finde, man sieht nicht mehr. Also, ich benutze das nie. Ich benutze immer die normale Ansicht.
Ich finde es ein bisschen doof, dass man die Kamera auch nicht ein bisschen noch kippen kann,
weil manchmal möchte man nämlich nicht... Also, man kann ja nicht über die Karte navigieren. Ich
kann jetzt nicht hier draufklicken und dann läuft meine Party dahin. Es wäre cool, wenn man die
Kamera ein bisschen neigen könnte, dass ich beispielsweise sagen könnte, ah, ich will jetzt
hier hinlaufen. So, und dann da hinklicken und dann laufen die dahin. Ah, habe ich schon.
Die Kamera buggt tatsächlich öfters. Wobei ich sagen muss, das verzeihe ich dem Game. Die haben
so viel Zeug eingebaut. Also, ich finde, da stören mich so Kleinigkeiten auch nicht. Bei anderen Games
würde ich dann sagen, ja, okay, so und so viel und dann funktioniert nicht mal die Kamera richtig.
Aber es funktioniert ja zum größten Teil und ein bisschen nervig ist es, gerade wenn du
unterschiedliche Höhen auf der Map hast, dann buggt die Kamera mal ganz gerne. Okay,
wie es unter AMD ist, weiß ich nicht. Kann das sein, dass ich Liazel oder wie sie heißt,
diesen Fight komplett vergessen habe? Die sitzt einfach nur da rum und macht nix. Moment,
die ist überhaupt nicht im Fight dabei. Deswegen habe ich die die ganze Zeit vergessen. Ach so,
die ist überhaupt nicht Teil vom Fight. Na toll, super. So, was haben wir hier denn jetzt?
Looten, überladen. Ja, ich muss unbedingt zum Lager. Was ist das? Waldweitschild,
fesselnder Schlag der Waldweit. Immerhin haben sie sich Mühe gegeben, das zu übersetzen. Okay,
was, was macht das Ding? Ach, das ist entangled. Verstehe. Fesselnder Schlag der Waldweit. Alles
klar. Gut zu wissen. Auf Will, gib mal Gas. Wir hatten, wir hatten hier noch Platz im Info.
Shadowheart, Shadowheart trägt noch gar nix. Jawohl. Wait, wait a minute. Hmm, warum genau
habe ich ein abgetrenntes Bein und einen abgetrennten Arm im Inventar? Vor allem
wiegt das acht Kilo. Habe ich das, ist das von irgendeiner Quest übrig? Ich kann mich nicht
daran erinnern, das aufgehoben zu haben. Egal, wir schmeißen das mal weg. Will, Will, wo läufst
du hin? Du sollst, du sollst das Bein wegschmeißen. Will, Bein. Hier, gut. Jetzt,
jetzt können wir in die Truhe gucken. Was haben wir hier? Funkelhände, Leitner,
schalte. Waffenloser Angriff. Okay, da bräuchte man einen Mönch oder irgendwie sowas. Habe ich
nicht. Hast du vergessen aufzuheben? Das Viech hier. Elixier. Ich benutze, ich habe Alchemie
noch nicht einmal benutzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert. Irgendwie hier drüber. Nee,
ich bin komplett planlos, was Craften in solchen Spielen angeht. Alchemie, Feuer, K drücken. Ah,
Dacogun. Ehrlich gesagt brauche ich nix davon. Wahrscheinlich muss man erst mal Rezepte sammeln,
dass sich das lohnt vermutlich. So, haben wir hier oben noch was? Vase und dann noch was.
Dornige Rohrkolben. Ein leiser Kolben ist das. Warum sieht das Gebiet bei ihm so schön aus?
Warum nicht? 4090 RTX. RTX enabled. Och man, Will ist schon wieder überladen. Nee,
Will ist nicht überladen. Will läuft durchs Wasser. Was hat er denn hier? Ah, Temporary
Hitpoints. Bei mir war das alles dunkel und düster. Ja, ich weiß, dass das früher oder später so
kommt. Ich kenne das von Screenshots. Chico, was los? Moment, Chico ist an der Tür. Katze raschelt an
der Tür. Ich mache die Tür auf. Katze dreht sich um und geht weg. Dann nicht, Chico. Die wollen
wahrscheinlich, dass ich mit rauskomme. So, hier geht's nicht weiter. Wie gesagt, das habe ich
auf Screenshots auch gesehen, dass der Sumpf dann irgendwann nicht mehr so schön ist. Sieger. Ja,
die wollten mich gebanen. Ein weiterer Punkt. Wie gesagt, ich spoiler die Main Quest nicht. Ich
muss aber sagen, so rein im ersten Akt, ich meine, weiter war ich noch nicht. Rein im ersten Akt,
muss ich sagen, ist die Story bisher sehr, ja, wenig präsent. Es gibt tausend Nebenquests. Die
Main Story ist eigentlich nicht so groß vorhanden. Okay, der wusste nicht, wie er da rüberkommt. Ich
denke aber mal, das wird die nächsten paar Akte ein bisschen anziehen. Wir wollten uns zu den
Schafen. Was war hier? Wahrnehmung fehlgeschlagen. Kiste oder Falle? Ich vermute mal Falle. Ich
laufe jetzt einfach nicht weiter rum. Ja, die Schafe wollen ja nicht mit mir reden, obwohl ich mit
Tieren reden kann. Ah, hier ist ein Teleporter. Nice. Du hast 26 Stunden, Akt eins durch. Ich
habe auch nicht mehr so viel übrig. Guck, also ich habe die meisten, die meisten Sachen habe
ich schon. Ich, ich habe, ich, hier oben habe ich noch was übrig. Das ist, das ist Akt zwei und ich
habe noch das komplette Underdark übrig. Da habe ich noch gar nichts gemacht. So, jetzt haben wir
so viele Spells rausgehauen. Jetzt gehe ich erst mal eine Runde pennen. Also Underdark war ich noch
gar nicht. Underdark habe ich mal, Teleporter mir aufgemacht und bin gleich wieder raus, weil ich
mir gedacht habe, das hebe ich mir nochmal aus. Auto auswählen. Übrigens, man muss auch nicht.
Oh, mein Aulbär ist am Start wieder. White Paper Happy. White Paper Happy. Okay, was machen wir?
Die Wunde untersuchen. Quatsch, ich greife dir bestimmt nicht an. Also Natur, okay, Natur bringt
was, weil ich bin High IQ Wizard. High IQ Wizard hat plus vier Intelligenzwurf. Alles gut, das nehmen
wir. Die Wunde untersuchen. Plus vier High IQ. Oh, gibt es noch Guidance oben drauf? Okay, da können,
also guck mal, Leute, wir müssen eine eins. Ja, also fünf bis acht Bonus. Also wir sollten nicht,
nicht niedriger als fünf würfeln. Ja, geschafft. Weiter. Heilkunde, versuche die Verletzung zu
heilen. Guidance. Okay, Präge, Präge. Oh Gott. Okay, Doktor wird aus Gail nicht mehr. Oh, fuck,
Alter. Oh, armes Viech. Nein. Oh, Mann. Nee, ich lade nicht neu. Ich will nicht zu sehr. Ich will
nicht zu sehr Selbstkampf. Ich meine, unsere Chancen waren eigentlich richtig gut, ja? Zehn
ist schon mal eh 50 50. Da hatten wir noch Guidance obendrauf. Aber eins, Mann. Oh, das ist so richtig
verkackt gewesen. Also zu Gail werde ich nicht gehen, wenn ich mich operieren lasse. So, wir
müssen mal ein bisschen was in der Kiste abladen. Will, komm mal her. Geh mal zur Kiste und schmeiß
da mal ein paar Sachen rein. Warum habe ich da ein Fass drin? Ah, weil es ein Fass ist, was
Damage macht, falls man das mal gebrauchen kann. Okay, Gewicht. Gold. Nicht wert, nicht wert.
Gewicht. Seil. Jawohl, alles da rein hier. Kann man das eigentlich schneller machen?
Irgendwie was? Ich könnte auch zu einem Händler gehen und verkaufen, aber no pass. Mache ich
nachher. Warum ich 500 Fackeln habe, weiß ich auch nicht. Gewicht. Perfekt. Ich glaube, das reicht
jetzt. Ich glaube, diese ganzen Sachen kann man direkt aus der kann man eh die Lagervorräte kann
man doch in die Kiste machen und die werden dann aus der Kiste genommen. Was ist das? Okay,
jetzt kann Will wieder ein bisschen was tragen. Du kannst auch Gegenstände von überall in deine
Kiste. Ja, das weiß ich, das weiß ich. Ach so, mit mit Control kann man das. Das wusste ich nicht.
Lass das mal ausprobieren. Inventar. Probieren wir mal aus hier. Gewicht. Bringt das was? Nein,
bringt nix. Sollst du einen Bonus von plus 1? Nee, bringt mir nix. Was mit Control? Kannst du
mehrere Sachen auswählen? Ah, das wusste ich nicht. Gut, gut zu wissen. Ah, das ist cool. Das ist sehr
nützlich. Das ist sehr nützlich. Okay, nice. Kann man auch, kann man auch. Lass das mal ausprobieren.
Kann man auch sagen, Gewicht. Ich wähle jetzt das hier aus. So. Ganzen, wobei, Wurfsperre brauche
ich noch. Diesen ganzen Mist wähle ich hier aus. So, und jetzt sage ich rechtsklick, an Lager
senden. Ah, guck dir mal da wieder was gelernt. Ah, nice. Ja, das macht das Handling dann doch
schon um einiges einfacher. Ah, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack. Was hat Gale hier eigentlich alles
für Müll dabei? Zack, zack, zack, zack. Alles weg hier. Und jetzt ans Lager senden. Nice. Oh, Chat,
hat sich doch heute schon mal wieder gelohnt. Das wusste ich nicht. Ich dachte, ich muss irgendwie
meine, meine Items von Hand rein track und droppen. Ja, dass man das ans Camp senden kann,
das weiß ich. Aber ich wusste nicht, dass man mit Control mehrere Sachen selekten kann. Okay,
das finde ich extrem nice. Das hat, Chat, hat sich schon mal, hat sich schon mal gelohnt. Hat
sich schon mal gelohnt. Nice. So, jetzt hat nämlich Will auch wieder Platz. Jetzt geht's
weiter. Safe. Ich hoffe, ich habe den Owlbear jetzt nicht komplett verkrault, dass der nie
wieder zu mir ins Lager kommt. Let's go. Will, du kommst oben hin. Du beschwörst den Hund. Dann
castet mein Cleric einmal Light auf sie und, ja, okay, und Gale castet Light auf Shadowheart.
Umgedreht machen können. So, let's go. Sind wir ready? Jetzt kommen wir zur Hexe in die,
in die Hütte. Zur vermeintlichen Hexe, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es eine Hexe ist.
Das wurde schon, das wurde schon so angeteasert. Welche Quest ist das eigentlich? Bei den Künstlern
gab es dazu noch gar keine Quest. Also, wir haben zwei Brüder getroffen, die ihre Schwester gesucht
haben. So, und da sind wir einer alten Oma über den Weg gelaufen und die wurde beschuldigt,
dass sie die Schwester entführt hat. Dass es angeblich eine Hexe ist. So, und die Alte,
die hat schon einen sehr sus Eindruck gemacht. Das heißt, ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
dass es eine Hexe ist. Und ich weiß auch, dass es eine Hexe ist, weil ich habe im Vorfeld ein
bisschen Sachen über das Game mir angeguckt. Kann das sein, dass mein Stream laggt, Leute?
Nö, kann nicht sein. Ist die Qualität in Ordnung so? Muss ich das mal anschauen. Ich bin mir nämlich
immer nicht sicher, ob das mit der Bitrate für Spiele passt. Ich glaube, nö, glaube ich geht
eigentlich ganz gut. Klar, oder? Ich meine, was ich, was ich machen kann, ist, ich könnte mal
den Output tatsächlich mal ein Mbit hochstellen. Ja, das können wir mal machen. Bei Gaming-Sachen
muss man immer schauen. Hat das jetzt gecheckt eigentlich? Ja, Facecam kommt dann bei Baldur's
Gate 4. Ja, auf geht's. Schäbige Holztür. Let's go, Will.
Die ist so auffällig freundlich. Die ist so auffällig freundlich, die hatten bestimmt recht,
dass das eine Hexe ist. Das ist Marina. Ich habe schlechte Neuigkeiten für sie. Ihr habt ein
interessantes Handschuh. Ja, das ist tatsächlich Marina, der ihre Brüder wir umgebracht haben
vorhin. Offstream. Marina leckt Critical Information. Ich glaube, wir sollten Marina
auch nicht erzählen, dass wir ihre Brüder umgebracht haben vorhin. Schön, dass ihr eine
sichere Reise hattet. Komm, wir sind, wir sind mal nett zu Alten. Wir könnten natürlich auch,
wir können mal gucken, was die so zu bieten hat. Trank der Unsichtbarkeit. Ja, nix tolles. Tolles
Zeug, auch mal nicht. Schön, dass ihr eine sichere Heimreise hattet oder sichere Reise. Komm, wir
sind auch mal nett. Wir sind, wir erzählen Marina nicht, dass wir ihre Brüder gekillt haben
aus Versehen vorhin. Ja, bestimmt, bestimmt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich der, was davon erzählt,
woher wisst ihr das, dass nicht eure sagen, es stimmt was nicht. Das stimmt was nicht. Diese
Frau, warum ist sie mit euch hier? Wie gesagt, ich vermute, die Alte ist eine Hexe.
Ich traue der nicht, aber mal gucken, mal gucken, wenn ich meine, ich kann sie danach
fragen. Könnt ihr den Parasiten entfernen? Hexenmeister, sowas hat meistens seinen Preis,
worum geht es euch wirklich? Ja, klar.
Ja, das ist bei Will schwierig. Will hat nur noch ein Auge. Also das ist keine normale Alte,
die die Marina einfach weg zaubert. Was gibt's denn hier sonst noch? Rief von M. Okay,
pass mal auf, ich klaue da jetzt mal was. Sieht bestimmt keiner. Okay, das war nix,
was man für eine Quest braucht. Alter, Will, attach dich. Haben wir hier irgendwas? Holztruhe.
Oh, was sind das da hinten? Akane Barriere. Tür aufmachen können. Moment, Moment,
Moment. Tür aufmachen können wir schon. Pass mal auf. Gail ist, Gail ist mein expert Lockpicker.
Die Alte sieht das nicht, oder? Nee, nee, die steht da unten irgendwo. Bonus Guidance.
Schwierigkeitsgrad zwei. Okay, das ist nicht mal wirklich abgeschlossen. Okay,
was haben wir hier? Akane Barriere. Da ist ein Schild. Finger weg. Okay,
lass mal was ausprobieren. Shit. Nee, einfach wegblasen kann man's nicht. Okay,
hier stimmt doch irgendwas nicht. Hier stimmt doch irgendwas nicht. Was ist ne Illusion? Der,
ach, was ist ne Illusion? Stimmt, wo ist denn die Alte hin? Die weg? Hä? Weg? Anscheinend. Ja,
dann ist die wahrscheinlich hier rein. Dann gehen wir doch mal gucken. So,
ich bin vollständig gerestet. Ich habe alle Spells da. Schauen wir mal. Was gibt's denn
hier unten im Keller? Sieht sehr einladend aus. Oh, Autosave. Autosave ist immer gefährliches
Zeichen. Kommt heute noch Progress? Stell's weiß nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich hab noch zwei.
Oh. Wonka S? Das ging schnell. Eben war's noch die nette Oma und jetzt ist sie hier als Hexer
direkt am Start. Ich hab ja gedacht, sie haben noch irgendeine Transformationsanimation oder
sowas. Aber nope. Ist auch überhaupt nicht verdächtig, ne? Man steht mit vier Leuten
in seinem Haus und auf einmal verschwindet man durch den Kamin und lässt die Leute alleine im
Haus. Das ist überhaupt nicht verdächtig oder so. Das ist mein Vergnügungshäuschen. Sag mir,
wo Marina ist, sonst was. Ich glaube, ich bleibe noch ein bisschen verzangen. Ich geh natürlich
so. Naja. Nee, ich geh bestimmt nicht. Raus hier, sonst was.
Haben wir den Looten? Natürlich.
Versteinert? Wait a minute. Moment, hab ich nicht. Das trage ich seit Ewigkeiten mit mir
rum. Verwandelt eine versteinerte Kreatur wieder zurück in eine organische Gestalt. Wollen wir das
mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert? Das wäre extremly six head, wenn das funktionieren würde.
Werfen. Versteinert. Ja, heb Versteinert auf. Das funktioniert! Nice, das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich bin hier, um zu helfen. Ich habe den Versteinerungszauber aufgehoben. Ihr seid
im Versteck einer Fettel. Warum nicht Hexe? Ich bin hier, um zu helfen. Okay.
Was? Ihr seid krank? Ist das ansteckend?
Okay. Wir können mal was ausprobieren. Ich kann ihn auch nicht wiederbeleben. Das wäre es
jetzt gewesen. Ich dachte, ich könnte ihn heilen oder so. Aber wisst ihr, was wir machen können?
Ich glaube, ich habe noch eine Speak with Dead-Rolle. Nee. Dead? Ach nee, Tod. Ich muss ja
auf Deutsch gucken jetzt. Methodensprechend-Schriftrolle. Geheilt? Wart ihr denn krank?
Das wissen wir schon. Wie heißt ihr? Was ist euch zugestunden? Was könnt ihr mir über die Fettel
erzählen? Ja, alles klar. Geheilt? Wart ihr denn krank? Ja, das wissen wir schon. Okay. Deadge
wieder. Aber wichtig, erstmal looten. Perfekt. Tragisch, ja, aber muss gelootet werden. Beutel.
Lüstermaske. Was haben wir hier am Start? Oh, da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht draufklicken,
aber okay. Keine Zeit zu schwätzen, ich will die Fettel. Was ist beim letzten Mal
so? Nee. Wir fliehen nicht. Wir machen jetzt die Hexe kalt.
Ach, deswegen will er niemanden mehr durchlassen. Ich meine es ernst, lass mich schreien. Gibt es
einen anderen Weg her? Die Hexe wird dein geringstes Problem sein, wenn du nicht aufmachst.
Ach, ich kann durch dich hindurchblinken, ich kann reingehen.
Was ist mit ihm hier?
Alles in Ordnung, was genau nicht ansehen. Alles in Ordnung.
Hey, seht mich an, was macht ihr da verschwindet? Was macht ihr da verschwindet? Ja,
mach dich vom Acker. Okay, der ist komplett durch. Warum sollte ich euch was tun? Ihr seid
bei mir sicher. Oh, okay, der blickt doch ganz gut durch. Ja, dass er das erkannt hat. Oh,
da ist was. Auf Leute, kommt mal zusammen. So, jetzt war mal Trick 17. Kommt mal weg hier,
Jungs und Mädels, haut mal da ab. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wofür der Imp richtig gut ist. Der
Imp ist quasi Sexhead-Imp. Er kann sich unsichtbar machen und dann kann ich mit dem Imp hier rum
fliegen und gucken, was hier so abgeht. Und keiner sieht ihn. Okay, einer Level 4, 29 HP,
das ist ja nix, easy. So, was haben wir hier oben? Level 4, 23, Level 4, 36. Okay,
vier Level 4er, das ist ja nix. Die sollten wir eigentlich locker, da können wir einfach uns
gestellt hier reinlaufen. Und am besten, am besten kriege ich das initiale, initialen Damage
irgendwie hier raus. Perfekt, genau hier hin will. Weg ist unterbrochen, den kann ich ancasten. Okay,
Shadowheart, du kommst auch mal mit vor. Gale, du kommst auch mit, aber nicht ganz so weit vorne
hin und Liaselle, du gehst, ja, du kommst auch mit vor. Eigentlich kann die sogar, theoretisch,
ich meine, ich könnte da hinporten und einfach mal mit dem Schwert draufhauen. Okay, das probiere
ich jetzt, ob das funktioniert. Easy. Ich glaube, ob das funktioniert. Direkt, jawoll. Okay,
der wird jetzt einfach weggeburstet. Zack, dead. Ein Treffer noch, hinüber, nice, easy. Der
nächste auch gleich. Action Surge, gib ihm. Damit haben die nicht gerechnet. Erstmal,
Fight fängt an, zwei Stück tot. So muss das sein. So, jetzt kommt Will. Jetzt kommt Will. Will
Eldricks blastert den Typ. Moment, die anderen sind noch nicht im Fight. Das, das verwirrt mich
jetzt. Gale? Okay, Gale. Ja, keine Ahnung. Einfach keine Ressourcen verschwenden. Dead. Und
als letztes noch Shadowheart. Shadowheart haut einfach von hinten drauf. Oh, nice. Nee,
ich spar mir, ich spar mir alle Spell Slots. Ja gut, die haben ja schon ihre, ihre Action quasi
raus. Aber mein Hund noch nicht. Mal dash. Der kommt hier nicht lebend raus. Bleibst du hier?
Jetzt haut er einfach ab. Wow. Au. Okay, gut, dass ich die geambushed habe. Die machen ja doch
ordentlich Damage. Daschen wir mal in die Richtung. Okay, der hat noch 23. Wir verschwenden
keine Ressourcen. Wir machen die mit Cantrips platt. Eldricks Blast. Ich hoffe, der fällt jetzt
nicht hier hinten runter und ich kann ihn nicht looten. Nein, macht er nicht. Easy Fight. Gut,
schauen wir mal, was die dabei haben. Flüstermaske. Tannchen Ethel sagt Hallo,
Schätzchen. Nee, das ziehe ich bestimmt nicht auf, das Ding. Verpflichtende Notiz. Lesen. Okay,
keine Questaktualisierung. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man hier drinnen rasten kann. Wenn man
hier drinnen rasten kann, dann warum eigentlich? Ich meine, ich habe ja mehr oder weniger alles.
Eine Short Rest sollte reichen. Short Rest vorm Bosskampf und dann habe ich ja wieder fast alles.
Ja, das ist das, was ich meine. Du kannst in dem Game gefühlt jeden Fight irgendwie cheesen. Ich
will nicht sagen, Leute, war das eben ein gecheester Fight? So ein bisschen, oder? Ich meine, wir haben
uns reingeschlichen, haben Turn-Based-Modus angemacht, sind so ran gesprungen, dass wir zwei
Gegner direkt Two-Hitten konnten und dann sind wir einzeln mit den Charakter in den Fight noch
reingegangen. Also ein bisschen gecheest war es vielleicht, ja. Geht es hier nicht weiter? Doch,
hier geht es weiter. Oh, was ist das? Schädliche Dämpfe. Nee, Moment, nicht Misty Step. Springen.
Autosave. Geil. Oh, guck mal hier, was für... Das ist coole Details. Meine Fackel ist ausgegangen,
weil ich gerade, weil ich gerade durchs Wasser gesprungen bin. Jetzt muss ich die Fackel
wahrscheinlich neu anbauen. Okay, das ist cool. Das ist cool. Oh, oh. Lauf, lauf nicht da rein,
nicht da reinlaufen, Hund, Hund, Hund. Wo gehst du hin? Alter. Low-IQ-Hund. Low-IQ-Hund. Was
willst du da machen? Richtig Three-Head-Hund. Okay, jetzt ist die Frage, wie komme ich hier
durch? Wahrnehmung fehlgeschlagen, okay. Das fängt ja schon mal gut an. Dann machen wir die
anderen auch mal raus und gucken, ob bei denen auch die Wahrnehmung fehlschlägt. Ah, Wahrnehmung
erfolgreich. Was haben wir denn hier? Seltsame Blume, Falle und Entlüftung. Okay, wahrscheinlich
müssen wir die Falle... Oder, ne, die Entlüftung ist verstopft. Hä? Ne. Seltsame Blume. Nur mal für
den Fall der Fälle, dass das explodiert. Das macht Larian Games gerne. Das war in Divinity auch schon
immer so, dass auch laufend alles explodiert. Und jetzt? Geht das jetzt weg? Ne. Kann ich das
anzünden und dann geht's weg? Ah. Ne. Wie jetzt? Okay, das geht nicht weg. Entschärfen. Jetzt bin
ich... Okay, kann ich das vielleicht kaputt machen? Ich werd einfach durchlaufen. Ich mein,
ich hab... Ich hab nen Spell gegen Gift. Ich hab nen Spell gegen Gift. Vielleicht sollte ich Gale
einfach Gift-Immun oder nahe zu Gift-Immun machen und den dann reinschicken zum Entschärfen. Falls
das überhaupt geht. Schauen wir mal. Zauberbuch, Shadowheart. Schutz vor Gift. Ich hab's sogar
ausgerüstet. Schutz vor Gift. Der Imp? Ne, der Imp, der kann nix... Der kann nix bedienen. Guck,
mal gucken, ob der Imp überhaupt Damage kriegt. Der sollte nur Hälfte Damage von Poison kriegen.
Noch gar nix. Ne, guck, der Imp kann nix bedienen. Das ist ein bisschen doof an dem Imp. Das wär aber,
glaub ich, zu OP. Ah, Moment. Hab ich nicht Mage Hand? Magierhand, 10 Züge. Ist das ein Cantrip?
Oder ist Mage Hand... Mage Hand ist ein Cantrip. Nice. Aha. Hä, Pogu. Schwierigkeitsgrad 30. Okay,
ich hab keine Chance, das zu schaffen, außer ne 20 zu würfeln. 30! Sonst geht's noch, ja? Ich
mein, ich muss 20 würfeln, dass das funktioniert. 30, Alter. Ja, ich hab nur ne 20 gewürfelt mit
Bonus. Keine natural 20. Tja, Patch gehabt. Okay, hier ist noch ne Falle, hier ist noch ne Falle.
Ich kann da nicht einfach... Wenn ich da einfach durchrenne, dann bin ich dead. So, wir machen mal
ne kurze Rast. Brauchen wir eh. So, heilen. Und dann, wenn wir durch sind, machen wir noch ne
kurze Rast. Was kann da rauskommen aus dem Würfel? Äh, was meinst du? Alter, was ist das hier?
Three-Head-Steuerung wieder. Eben das Ding mit dem 20. Naja, was rauskommen kann, 1 bis 20 kann da
rauskommen. Plus Bonus. Also, du würfelst 1 bis 20 und dann gibt's noch verschiedene Boni, die du
oben drauf bekommen kannst, ja? Also, zum Beispiel, deswegen find ich's auch immer blöd, wenn Leute
ohne Cleric spielen. Cleric hat so, hat nen Spell für... Weiß gar nicht, ob man den manuell machen kann.
Guidance. Ja, göttliche Führung heißt es auf Deutsch. Da kriegst du 1 bis 4 nochmal Bonus
oben drauf. Dann kriegst du noch Bonus, je nachdem wie gut du mit Fallen entschärfen bist. Und wenn
du ne 20 würfelst ohne Bonus, ist es immer erfolgreich. Und wenn du ne 1 würfelst, also
auch, egal ob mit oder ohne Bonus, ist es immer, schlägt es immer Fehl. Okay, Leute, ich hab keine
Ahnung, was ich machen soll. Ich glaub, ich renne jetzt einfach... Moment, guck mal, hier unten kann
man auch lang. Das ist da, wo der Hund hin wollte, oder? Wir können auch... Okay, Leute, passt mal auf.
Shadowheart hat doch Misty Step. Einmal pro kurze Rast. Okay, ich mach eh ne kurze Rast gleich, wenn ich
unten bin, bevor der Bossfight kommt. Kann ich mit Shadowheart nicht einfach... Na gut, ich kann da
hinten Misty Steppen und dann bringt mir ja nix. Kann man hier rüberspringen vielleicht? Kann man
vielleicht von hier einfach rüberspringen? Ja, okay, easy. Was macht ihr da für nen Scheiß, Leute?
Three-Head-NPCs, Alter. Three-Head hoch 10, Mann. Ihr habt die Falle erkannt und springt dann einfach
rein. Richtig dumm, Alter. Richtig hängen geblieben. Okay, hier hat er aber was erkannt. Wir müssen eh ne
short Rast machen gleich noch. Passt schon. Oh, hier ist noch ne Falle. Der Weg ist unterbrochen. Ja, okay.
Game, darf ich jetzt? So, weißt du was? Ich renne jetzt einfach durch. Da kommt ja sonst nix mehr, oder?
Wo geht's denn hier weit? Komm, wisst ihr was? Ich mach eh ne short Rast. Ich save jetzt, bevor wir noch ewig rummachen.
Ich renne jetzt einfach durch. Leute, was macht ihr da? Alter, jetzt kommt halt mal runter, Mann. Ich glaub's
nicht, Alter. Low-IQ-Wegfindung. Oh, Mann. So war das nicht gedacht. So war das jetzt nicht geplant, ja. Ist das auch noch ne Falle hier unten?
Okay, komm. Nochmal short Rast. Nice. Und wenn du 20 bekommst, hättest du krassen Loot bekommen. Ne, mit 20 hätte ich die Falle entschärft.
Ich muss 30 würfeln, damit ich die Falle entschärfen kann. Oder ne 20 ohne Bonus, weil dann ist es immer erfolgreich.
Also, ich hätte es mit meinen Charakters gar nicht wirklich schaffen können. Ah, guck. Gail hat ne plus 3 wegen seiner Geschicklichkeit auf Fallen entschärfen.
Guck, der hat 16, der hat plus 3 auf Geschicklichkeitswürfe. Und da krieg ich noch Guidance. Also, ich hätte 30 mit keinem meiner Charakter schaffen können.
Der hätte ich irgendwie Astarion oder so mitnehmen müssen. Der weiß nicht, ob der gute Fallen entschärfen kann.
Wie krieg ich denn dieses Ding jetzt weg da unten? Das war ne Falle, ja. Okay, ich mein, wir sind in halbwegs guter Verfassung hier runter gekommen.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal eine Sache und zwar machen wir nicht Prayer of Healing. Wir wollen, oh mein Shadowheart hat doch sowas, dass man maximale Trefferpunkte, ich glaub 8 heißt das auf Englisch statt Zauber, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wo der hier ist.
Beistand. Heile deine Verbünde, höhere Trefferpunkte um 5. Genau, das mein ich. Gebet der Heilung brauchen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich, das ist eh nur Out of Combat Heal. Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht, dafür nehmen wir Beistand rein.
Der Rest ist eigentlich ganz sinnig. Also besten 3 Cleric Spells, die man immer mitnehmen muss. Bless, Spiritual Weapon, Spirit Guardians. Spirit Guardians ist der krasseste OP Zauber, den es in dem, okay wie sind Baldur's Gate, das weiß ich nicht, aber eines der OPsten Zauber, die es in Dungeons und Dragons gibt.
Den werden wir gleich auch verwenden. Oh hier sind ja nochmal, ist ja nochmal Gas. Okay, okay, NPCs bitte nicht 3head sein jetzt, okay? No 3head NPCs please. Ja sieht gut aus, sieht gut aus. Willst du nicht runterspringen? Okay, only 5head, no 3head. Nein, Will du sollst nicht in das Gas rennen.
Hund beschwören. So und dann wollte ich mir mit Shadowheart noch temporäre, nein Hund, Hund. Alter Hund, Hund, wie blöd kann man sein? Der hat keinen Bock, der will unbedingt in das Gas rennen. Dabei wäre der richtig gut gewesen jetzt mit erhöhten Trefferpunkten und so, na gut.
Okay, dann, dann machen wir das ohne den Hund. Auf geht's, Shadowheart. Gib mir mal eine Runde extra HP. Wie jetzt? Ach ich dachte es heilt mich auch noch zusätzlich. Ah jetzt müsste ich noch ne Short Rest hinten drauf hauen oder, na hab ich aber nicht mehr.
Naja, egal, let's go. Let's go.
Oh. Lass mich hier zurück. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Wir retten dich gleich. Können wir uns hier irgendwie rein? Oh, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Pass mal auf, wir stelzen uns jetzt da runter. 5head stelzt Action.
Hab ich nicht, Moment. Hat Shadowheart nicht Path Without Trace als Trickery Cleric? Ne, Selbstverkleidung, Segen. Ne, ich brauch das für die Gruppe. Hat, Moment, das muss ich mal kurz nachgucken.
Äh, Baldur's Gate 3 Trickery Cleric. Kriegen die nicht? Kriegen die nicht Gruppen, Gruppen Stelz? Irgendwann? Path Without Trace. Wieso, hab ich doch. Level 3, Domain Spells, Path Without Trace. Warum hab ich das nicht? Ah, hab ich doch. Ach, Spurloses Gehen. Okay, Alter, ich, ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hätt's besser auf englisch stehen lassen.
Ähm, so. Du beschwörst einen Schleier aus Schatten und Stille, der dir und allen Gefährten in Reichweite einen Bonus von plus 10 auf Würfe aufhal- Okay, keine Ahnung, ob ich das brauch. Komm, scheiß drauf, wir gehen jetzt ohne, ohne Gruppen Stelz da rein. Die krieg ich nicht da runter, was ist denn das hier? Steuerkugel. Kann ich mich da lang stelzen, ohne dass die Hexe das checkt? Das geht doch bestimmt nicht, geht doch nicht.
Dehehe, war klar. Oh. Wow, what the f- Ähm, okay, das ist garantiert irgendwelche Mirror Image Magic oder sowas.
Kann man vielleicht Tricksen untersuchen? Bisschen Metagamen? Was? Nee, oder? Die sehen alle gleich aus. Im Zweifelsfall ist es die am weitesten von mir entfernte. 1, 2, 3, an die 2 komm ich nicht dran. 2, 3, 4.
Das ist die echte. Fake, fake Hexe. Echte, echte Hexe gefunden. Okay. Gail, du darfst gleich nächste Runde auf den Knopf drücken. Dann ist jetzt die Hexe- Ah, Moment, die Dinger kriegen- Ach, die kriegen alle ihren eigenen Turn. Okay, dann sollte ich die vielleicht doch killen.
Und der Käfig ist fast kaputt. Aber das ist kein Problem. Chat, ich hab die Pfeilfeld-Idee. Wir ignorieren einfach den brennenden Käfig und, pass mal auf, ich hoffe das funktioniert. Wenn das nicht funktioniert, haben wir gelitten, dann müssen wir den Fight nochmal machen. Oder ich kann speichern, kurz bevor der Fight zu Ende ist.
Und wenn der Fight vorbei ist, dann packen wir bei Shadowheart Wasser erschaffen oder zerstören in Spellbook und löschen das mit Regen.
Pfeilfeld-Zeit. Okay, lass mal überlegen, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten? Ich würde sagen Spirit Guardians Misty Step auf die Hexe. Dürfte wahrscheinlich das Beste sein. Oder Spiritual Weapon. Aber das- Moment, Spiritual Weapon ist eine Bonus-Action, das heißt ich kann dann kein Misty Step mehr machen.
Okay. Spirit Guardians most OP Spell ever. Und jetzt Misty Step auf die Hexe.
Da muss ich mir mal vorstellen, irgendjemand bei den Dungeons & Dragons Design hat sich gedacht, es ist eine gute Idee in der quasi Tank-Klasse ein AE-Damage-Spell zu geben, der immer im Kreis um sich herum funktioniert.
Den man sogar noch abcasten kann für bis zu, fragt mich nicht, 7d8 oder so Damage. Also Spirit Guardians ist mega OP. Gut, bei einem einzelnen Gegner jetzt vielleicht nicht. Ich habe gehofft, dass das Radiant Damage an der ein bisschen mehr macht.
Okay, Shadowheart, du bist fertig. Gale, du kannst Gale da oben rein porten. Nee, das wäre witzig eher. Gale ist auch fertig. Liaselle ist am Start. Die wird jetzt Damage machen auf die Hexe. Und zwar mit ihrem krassen Flammenschwert.
Und die gibt der auch richtig mit Advantage. Rekt. Next. Und gleich Action Search nochmal. Jawoll. Action Search. So, wir können die auch... Okay, wir hauen noch einmal so drauf. Vorbei.
So, vielleicht haben wir Glück und das trifft. Okay, zwei Sachen. Entweder, wenn das trifft, machen wir gut Damage. Und zusätzlich, wenn wir Glück haben, gibt es noch 4 für die Hexe. Dann rennt die Hexe weg von mir die nächste Runde. Das wäre natürlich extrem OP. Dann haben wir eigentlich schon so gut wie gewonnen.
Oder Bluten für zwei. Leute, Sixhead-Idee. Sixhead-Idee. Passt mal auf. Ich weiß, was wir machen. Wartet mal. Will, du darfst jetzt erstmal verhexen die Hexe. Moment, was für ein Saving Throw ist denn bedrohlicher Angriff? Steht das da irgendwo?
Kann sich nicht bewegen, verhexen. Auf was muss die würfeln? Weisheit. Wisdom. Wisdom. Okay, also Sixhead-Time. Will debufft Wisdom auf die Hexe. Wo ist es denn? Weisheit. Ja, Will debufft die Hexe.
Dann, das hätte ich klein machen sollen. Und dann versuchen wir die Hexe noch in Angst zu versetzen. 55%ige Wahrscheinlichkeit zu treffen und dann muss die noch. Okay, aber wenn wir treffen, haben wir eine gute Chance wegen dem Debuff, dass die Hexe Angst bekommt.
Und. Ja. Oh, fuck. Okay, hat resisted. Na gut. Da machen wir nix. Dann kann Will. Wir hätten auch versuchen können, die Hexe in den Abgrund zu werfen. Aber da hätten wir sie nicht looten können. Auch blöd.
Okay, Leute, wisst ihr was? Ich will diese zwei Images. Krieg ich die? Game. Please. Game. Game. Ich möchte einen Fireball da oben hin machen und beide hitten. Okay, anscheinend klappt das nicht.
Ähm, da muss ich. Das ist halt auch ein bisschen blöd. Man erkennt leider nicht so richtig. Aber wenn ich da oben hingehe, geht bestimmt. Man erkennt leider nicht so richtig, ob die Gegner in Ziel. Aber jetzt passt das. Okay. Wie weg. Alter. Wie, warum ist der Weg jetzt unterbrochen? Wollte mich. Game. Wie der Weg ist. Und von was ist denn der Weg unterbrochen? Da ist doch überhaupt nix.
Moment. Jetzt ging's. Eben ging's. Sekunde. Ey, das ist ja voll von Arsch, Alter. Man kann's halt nicht richtig erkennen. Ich würde dann einfach den Fireball gerne hier oben in die Luft machen und beide treffen. Aber. Ja, nice. Ah, okay. Hier geht das. Alles klar. Obviously. Hier geht das. Sonst geht das nirgends wo. Wie. Manchmal ist das Game. Pega. Es wurde eindeutig angezeigt, dass ich beide Gegner treffe. Habe ich aber nicht. Sehr gut. GG.
Hier kann ich nix mehr machen. Super. Jetzt kriegt ihr halt noch einen Bonus. Jawoll. Au. Böse. Hat die resistet? Hat die resistet? Ja, ich glaub schon. Okay. Jetzt ist sie dran. 60 HP pro Runde müssten wir hinbekommen. In your face.
Den 4-Versuch mach ich zum Schluss, weil 4 wird durch Damage gebrochen. Kann Shadowheart noch irgendwas machen? Hmm. Spiritual Weapon? Nein, wir bürsten die jetzt weg. 55 bis 30 Damage. 55% Chance. Ich mach auf jeden Fall Damage die Runde, weil ich stell mich mit Spirit Guardians daneben und dann macht's Damage.
Ah, vorbei. Aber ich mach trotzdem Damage. Jawoll. Könnte ich? Wobei, wenn ich meine Bonus-Action doch noch habe, dann gibt's noch ein Spiritual Weapon daneben. Ja, easy.
Okay, Shadowheart, du bist fertig die Runde. Jetzt kommt Gale. Okay, Gale kann die finishen. Mein 28. Guck mal, ich hab noch dreimal Fireball übrig. Kann ich die Hexe treffen mit Fireball, ohne dass ich was anderes treffe? Ja, easy. Bam, Hexe tot. Der hat ge... Oh, Sekunde. Ah, ah, Turn-Based.
Sonst brennt mir nämlich der Käfig ab, wenn ich nicht Turn-Based einschalte. Okay, Turn-Based-Modus ist an. Jetzt müssen wir uns ein bisschen beeilen. Turn-Based-Modus ist an. Was heißt beeilen? Nee, wir haben Turn-Based-Modus an, wir müssen uns nicht beeilen.
Zielpunkt ist nicht erreichbar. Aber doch jetzt, oder? Was zum... Will mich das Game verarschen? Wie, Zielpunkt ist nicht erreichbar? Achso, ich muss erst hier was auswählen. Wasser erschaffen. Jawoll. Ha, Outplayed-Hexe, würde ich sagen. Easy.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Hexe zu looten hat. Okay. Geschafft. Ich würde sagen, die Alte lassen wir da oben im Käfig sitzen, oder? Wie geht das einfach hier? Okay, ich lasse dich runter, aber erst noch muss ich die Hexe looten. Man muss Prioritäten setzen. Hexe looten ist wichtiger als Gefangene befreien.
Was haben wir denn hier? Trank der Unsichtbarkeit. Corellonsknadel. Waffenlose Angriffswürfe. Keine Rüstung. Plus zwei auf Saving-Throws. Das ist für Gale nicht schlecht. Gale hat keine Rüstung an. Angelaufener Talisman. Macht es dem Träger einfacher, Todes retten. Brauch ich nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein ganz guter Stab für... Das ist ein ganz guter Stab für Gale.
Weil plus zwei Saving-Throws kann man ja mal nehmen. Rüstung trägt er auch nicht. Passt das ja. Was ist das? Silvanischer Stein. Ja, ist gut, ich lasse dich ja raus.
Was ist denn jetzt los? Was gibt denn das jetzt? Was gibt denn das jetzt? Ihr habt es ruiniert. Ich habe alles ruiniert. Wieso? Was habe ich getan? Tut mir leid, ich wollte... Nein. Im Leben nicht. Interessante Art, euch bei mir zu bedanken. Das brauche ich nicht. Viel Glück, hier allein weiterzugehen.
Okay, Chat. Ich persönlich tendiere ja zu vier. Ich vermute aber, wenn wir so eine doofe Antwort bekommen, gibt es keine ordentliche Belohnung oder keine Folge-Quest. Okay, drei ist auch okay. Interessante Art, euch bei mir zu bedanken. Nee, komm, wir nehmen drei. Das ist die etwas diplomatischere Art.
Kann man mit da traden? Okay, traden. Oh, ganze zwei Gold. Krasse Trader-Dude. So, interessante Art, euch bei mir zu bedanken.
Roten Beschwörung geht prinzipiell eigentlich nie gut. Dank Tanchin Ethel werdet ihr fast gestorben. Seid nicht so pleut. Die Vettel hätte euch nie geholfen. Vettel arbeitet nicht umsonst. Was habt ihr ihr versprochen? Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Ihr könnt...
Ihr wolltet euer Baby gegen euren toten Mann eintauschen. Mit Vetteln ist nicht je vorbei. Ihr müsst euch...
Eine gute Idee.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum die die nicht mit Hexe übersetzt haben. Also, in Englisch heißt das Hag und ich dachte eigentlich, dass Hag so mehr oder weniger Hexe ist. Ja.
Was ist Vettel? Was ist Vettel? Äh, Duden. Was sagt der Duden zu Vettel? Substantiv-Feminin-Abwertend. Ungepflegte, schlampige, alte Frau. Eieiei. Hate Speech. Sie hätten sie einfach mit Hexe und Gutfell gewesen.
Nach alledem denke ich, ihr werdet eine schreckliche Mutter. Nein, wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben.
Ihr hättet es besser wissen müssen. Hexen helfen immer nur nicht selbst. Hat euch das erzählt?
Ja, die sagt viel, wenn er tagelang ist. Deswegen ist sie auch eine Hexe.
Es ist der einzige Weg, wie dieses Kind seinen Vater jemals treffen wird. Ich hoffe, ihr seid glücklich.
Kann man. Oh. Kecke. Ups. Okay. Ich wollte die da nicht runterplassen. Okay. Ich wollte nur gucken, ob das geht. Ich wollte nur wissen, ob das geht. Das mache ich natürlich nicht. Ich wollte einfach nur checken, ob das möglich ist.
Wisst ihr, was mich echt interessieren würde? Ohne Missliste. Hallo. Game. Wisst ihr, was mich richtig interessieren würde? Wenn ich die kille. Ich will wissen, wie gut die das programmiert haben. Wenn ich die kille. Kann ich dann Speak with Dead machen? Und die beschwert sich noch bei mir.
Okay. Wie gesagt, ich lade gleich. Ich will das nochmal ausprobieren. Okay. Erstmal looten. Was hat die dabei? Okay. Maginas Medaillon. So. Speak with Schriftrolle mit Totensprechen. Zauberwirken. Also das muss man echt sagen. Die haben sich wirklich enorm viel Mühe mit dem Spiel gegeben, oder?
Wie gefühlt jeder NPC, den du killen kannst, der tot ist. Mit dem kannst du reden. Was ein Aufwand, Alter. Was ein Aufwand. Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Okay. Alles nicht passiert, Leute. Alles nicht passiert. Wir machen weiter. Ich wollte einfach nur gucken, ob es geht.
Okay. Echse gelootet. Gibt es hier sonst noch irgendwas? War hier sonst noch irgendwas für Loot-Action? Ne, anscheinend nicht. Scheint ja nicht immer auf dein Verhalten zu reagieren. Ja gut, das stimmt. Ich meine, normalerweise hätte die sich ein bisschen mehr darüber beschweren müssen, dass ich sie gerade umgebracht habe. Das ist schon richtig. Aber wir wollen jetzt mal nicht überanspruchsvoll sein.
Ja, ich habe letztens zum Beispiel auch gedacht, man kann in einer Quest einen Künstler retten. Und paar Minuten später hat mich Astarion gefragt, weil als Vampir sieht er ja nicht seine Spiegelung, wie er aussieht. Und eigentlich habe ich damit gerechnet, dass man als Antwort auswählen kann. Ich habe einen Künstler befreit, der kann ein Bild von mir malen oder sowas. Aber gab es nicht zur Auswahl.
Also, sie haben nicht an komplett alles gedacht, aber schon an sehr viel. Brief, das Auge, Trank der Geschwindigkeit, bittere Scheinung. Was bin ich da lootend gerade? Kannst du mal weggehen? Einblendung, please. Neueste. Das allsichtige Auge, Bandszauber, das erste gerade, Schutz.
Oh, das kann tatsächlich ganz nützlich sein. Das ziehe ich sogar mal Will an, der hat noch kein Medaillon. Oh, ein Epic Item. Das erste. Neueste.
Strahl der Übelkeit. Umwerfen. Aha, was, was? Ach ne, das ist Melee-Angriff. Vergifte das Ziel möglicherweise. 2d8 Schaden. Einmal einsetzbar pro kurze Rast. Gar nicht mal so schlecht. Ich glaube, das drücke ich Gale in die Hand.
Oh. Okay, passt nicht wirklich vom Style her zu Gale, aber ich mein, who cares. Oh, Gale eine Runde nackig. Leute, das will ich jetzt nicht. Also, das Game ist manchmal sehr freizügig. Ich hoffe, ich komme nicht in Probleme. Auf Twitch sollte irgendwie eine dieser Szenen dann kommen.
Was, was picke ich hier gerade ab? Was ist das, was ich hier, was ich hier aufhebe? Flaschen? Ja, also, der, oh, das ist ein Trank. Ne, ich trink das nicht. Ich trink das nicht. Untersuchen. Ach, hier sieht man, was es macht, oder was? Stichresi, okay, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine Taste, alles auf einmal aufzuheben. Gab's in Divinity auch nicht. Wir müssen mal kurz ins Wiki gucken. Da gibt's doch bestimmt, ach, guck mal. Da gibt's doch bestimmt, das will ich jetzt nicht alles ausprobieren. Lass uns doch mal kurz gucken, was diese ganzen Tränke machen.
Okay, unsinnig. Boah, das ist, Moment, warte mal. Ne, das ist komplett für den Arsch. Okay, das ist unsinnig.
Die kann man eigentlich wegschmeißen, die Potions. Okay, wollen wir wetten? Wir kommen jetzt an der Stelle raus, wo vorher dieses Arcane Siegel war, wo man nicht weiter konnte. Bevor ich rausgehe, probiere ich nochmal einmal, was passiert, wenn ich den, wenn ich den Kram kaputt mache.
Nichts großartig. Okay, next. Wer bin ich denn? Hä? Ach, da ist er. Marina. Angreifen. Nein, ich schlage jetzt nicht auf den Sarg einfach random ein.
In eine Schubkarre? Was zum Teufel hat die vor? Ich habe einen Zauberstab gefunden, ich kann euren Mann wieder... Habe ich? Ich habe einen Zauberstab gefunden, der den Mann wiederbeleben kann? Das wusste ich selber noch gar nicht. Gut, Game, dass du mir das sagst.
Ähm, okay. Habe ich das? Oder erzählt, oder gebatet er nur? Tatsächlich. Wo habe ich den her? Ich bin mir nicht bewusst, den aufgehoben zu haben. War das eben beim Blut von der Hexe dabei? Bestimmt vom Fettel, ja.
Oh. So hatte sich das nicht vorgestellt. Aber so ist das halt mit Totenbeschwörungen, das klappt nie so richtig. Oh, ich kriege einen Pet. Noch ein weiteres Pet. Ich will das aber gar nicht als Pet haben.
Hm, die Kreatur ist an den Stab gebunden, wie praktisch. Nee, ich bin ja ein guter Warlock. Ich habe keine untoten Sklaven und sowas.
Die Hexe hält also ihre Versprechen. Es kann wohl niemals einfach sein, was? Sie hat sich dran gehalten.
Das ist euer Ehemann. Wollt ihr ihn oder nicht? Wir können ihn jederzeit wieder bekramen. Chat, eins oder drei? Oder, oder, nee, wir machen das Viech nicht kaputt.
Okay, bestimmt noch Follow-Up-Quests. Das ist euer Ehemann. Wollt ihr ihn oder nicht? Okay, ich tendiere auch zu eins, Leute. Ich tendiere auch zu eins. Wollt ihr ihn oder nicht?
Soll ich dir wirklich den Zauberstab geben? Die baut doch damit garantiert irgendeine Scheiße wieder. Egal, komm, kriegst den Zauberstab.
Danke, aber wir brauchen mehr als Glück. Mehr als ein blödes Wunder. Ich werde einen Wizard finden oder so. Vielleicht kann jemand, der uns helfen kann.
Connor hat immer gesagt, man kann in dieser Stadt alles finden.
Erinnerst du dich? Und danke, glaube ich. Komm, Schatz. Los geht's.
Nein, ich springe dir nicht um. Ich wollte einfach nur mal gucken, ob es geht. Okay. Nice, wo geht ihr denn hin? Ey, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell. Okay, alle weg.
Hey, wo seid ihr hin? So, haben wir hier noch irgendwas? Wir looten jetzt erst mal das Hexenhaus.
Ach, guck mal, jetzt fällt es mir auch erst auf. Guck mal den Sumpf an. Ist jetzt gar nicht mehr so freundlich wie vorher, gell? Ist jetzt ziemlich sumpfig.
Schlüssel zum Teehaus, ja gut, brauche ich nicht. Looten. Trank sprechen mit Tieren brauche ich nicht.
Also meines Wissens gibt es keinen Knopf, um alles zu looten, Leute. Wenn ihr da mehr wisst, sagt mir Bescheid. Ah, ein Heiltrank, okay. Holztruhe. Heiltrank.
Noch mehr Heiltränke. Heiltrank ist immer gut. Noch eine Truhe. Nein, du sollst das hier, das sollst du looten.
58 Gold, okay, warum nicht? Gut, ich würde sagen, fertig gelootet. Ey, hier draußen ist noch was. Auf, bewegt euch. Aber schön viele Heiltränke, das finde ich schon mal sehr, sehr nice.
Okay, let's go. Oh, guck mal, da ist ein Brunnen. Was gibt es denn da? Brunnen. Kann bestimmt reinklettern.
Nicht wirklich, oder? Wobei ich neugierig bin, was passiert, wenn man trinkt. Okay. Schutz vor Gift? Will? Schutz vor Gift, Brunnen trinken. Vom Brunnen trinken.
Ach, die ist einverstanden. Da bin ich aber froh. Siehste? Hat sich ausgezahlt. Und das bringt jetzt was? Erfrischt 10 Treffer, boah, das ist richtig, ey, das ist mega viel, 10 Trefferpunkte.
Ich mein, guck mal, ein Gale hat 37 TP, der hat dann 47 danach. Mega. Die trinken jetzt alle mal davon. Die trinken jetzt einfach mal alles, das eklige Dreckswasser. Nice. Einfach alle mal 10 TP mehr.
Ach, wen haben wir denn da? Wer ist denn hier? Oh, wow. Ach, es gibt jetzt Gegner im Sumpf. Na gut, der Sumpf sieht ja auch nicht mehr so freundlich aus jetzt. Okay. Ich hab kaum noch Spells übrig. Das ist aber doof, dass ich jetzt fighten muss.
Na gut. Okay, dann machen wir kein Damage, sondern buffen uns mit Bless. Und zwar für, äh, fuck, Liathe, wie auch immer man die ausspricht, Shadowheart, zu hoch, okay, und, und Will.
Und wir heilen Will auch nochmal. Normalerweise, also, rein taktisch ist es nicht sinnvoll, mit dem Clary zu heilen. Man denkt sich zwar immer so, Clary ist der beste Heilcharakter im Game, naja, aber taktisch heilt man nur, wenn einer down geht. Man heilt nie im Voraus.
Oh, ich hab noch ein Fireball. Jawohl, Rotkäppchen. Na, ein bisschen wenig, oder? Ein Feuerball für einen lohnt sich ja nicht wirklich. Aber das können wir machen. Bam. Okay, Gale geht mal ein Stückchen zur Seite.
Next, Will. Eldricks Blastet den Typ jetzt einfach mal zurück, da wo er herkommt. Bam. Dead. Eldricks Blastet einfach der beste Cantrip ever. Rotkäppchen spurtet. Oh, da jetzt ein Fireball rein. Das ist ein Caster bestimmt. Äh, what? Was macht das?
Er kann dreimal angreifen. Okay, das Ding sollte ich killen, bevor es mich hittet. Gehen wir mal hier vor. Okay, vielleicht hab ich Glück und kann da was hitten.
Haben wir noch irgendwelche Fernkampf-Sachen? Spalten. Durchbohrender Schuss. Blutung für zwei Züge. Ja, das ist ganz gut. Mehr Damage ist immer gut. Jawohl. Nochmal. 43. Äh, heilen. Die kann sich mal selbst heilen. Zug beenden.
Okay, Shadowheart, komm mal hier vor. Und ich würde sagen, komm, du hast noch einen Spell-Slot frei. Mach, mach Damage.
Übrigens, äh, Lenkendes Geschoss ist eigentlich ein ziemlich, ziemlich nicer Clary-Zauber. Der macht für einen Level-1-Spell ziemlich viel Damage. Und der nächste Nahkampf-Angriff auf den Gegner, wenn er getroffen hat, hat Advantage. Also das ist wirklich ein gut investierter Spell-Slot.
So, und jetzt gibt's ein Fireball. Und dann sind sie dead-ge. Hehehehe. Wie? Keck Wade? Warum überlebt ihr das so einfach? Anzeige. Okay, Eldricks Blaster, den Typ mal weg.
Der kann aber weit springen. Hat, hat das jetzt getroffen? Tatsächlich? Nee. Ja, hat das jetzt getroffen oder nicht? Ach nee, hat ein Rettungswurf bestanden gegen Person festhalten. Okay, nein, hat nicht getroffen.
Ja, nicht die beste Armbrust-Schützin, aber besser als dahin zu rennen. Okay, ich hab keine Spell-Slots mehr. Bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig. Wow, das ist aber mutig. Jetzt gibt's Damage. Boah, der hat reingehauen.
Und jetzt wirst du nochmal bis zum Mond, Eldricks Blaster. Da fliegt er. Er juckt mich nicht, du bist dead. Kannst du noch so viel rummachen da vorne? So, ich muss jetzt eh ins Camp. Jawohl, nice, sehr schön.
Das heißt, der ganze Sumpf ist jetzt voller, voller Monster. Okay, naja gut. Irgendwie sieht der Sumpf ja auch nicht mal so freundlich aus, wie noch bevor ich die Hexe gekillt hab. Aber glücklicherweise hab ich schon den restlichen Sumpf mehr oder weniger erkundet, bis auf hier unten. Okay, das können wir jetzt schnell noch machen. Hier, hier unten haben wir noch nicht erkundet. Da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Denk an den NPC. Au, au. Offene Wunde. Au. Stimmt, mit dem NPC wollte ich noch hin. Wie jetzt? Alles fehlgeschlagen. Ja, dann muss ich den Hund holen. Hund hab ich auch nicht mehr. Der Hund kann nämlich auch erschnüffeln. Ja, das hat's jetzt ja super gelohnt.
Alle, alle, alle haben gefailt. Okay, wir kürzen das mal ab. Wir gehen jetzt eine Runde ins Lager pennen. Dann beschwören wir den Hund wieder. Der Hund schnuppert, was es da gab. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Hoffentlich kommt der Aulbär wieder. Oder Gail hat ihn mit seiner Medizinklanzleistung komplett verkrault.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wo die Falle war. Wo war die Falle? Oh, da ist noch ein Rotkäppchen. Hier muss der Hund schnüffeln. Verrottend. Was ist das denn? Oh, nee, nee, hier war die Falle irgendwo.
Errottend. Die offene Wunde wird Nachteil beat- Okay. Hund. Jawoll, Hund. Ich weiß, dass hier was ist. Komm her. Schnüffel mal eine Runde, please. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ja. Ich weiß, dass hier was ist. Ich war nur zu blöd, es selbst zu finden. Ja, ja, ja. Hier ist was, Hund. Hund, ich weiß, dass hier was ist.
Der hat keinen Bock. Der will nicht. Okay, dann lass es, dann lass es halt bleiben. Oh, was wir- Angeekelt. Verrottend. Wie kriegt man das wieder weg? Kann man das- Kann das ein Clary wiederherstellen? Okay, Wasser erschaffen brauchen wir wahrscheinlich nie wieder. Der Rest ist okay.
Äh, Lesser Restoration. Wo ist es denn? Schwache Genesung. Genau. Schwache. Ah, nee, das geht von alleine weg. Alter. Warum sind die denn am kotzen gerade?
Vielleicht ist es ein bisschen eklig hier jetzt in dem- in dem Sumpf. Ich habe aus dem Brunnen getroffen- Meinst du, dass es davon- Meinst du, deswegen ist es denen schlecht? Pass mal auf. Tubated. Wir rauben den jetzt einfach raus. Easy.
Die Hexe ist tot.
Ich habe die Hexe schon getroffen, ja. Ja, sie hat die Begegnung nicht überlebt.
Kein Problem.
Kill ich halt noch mehr Hexen.
Wen jagt ihr denn?
Ach, kommt. Ich habe schon Schlimmeres getötet. Ja. Guidons? Schwierigkeitsgrad 10. Sollten wir packen. Easy. Easy.
Na dann. Oh, den kenne ich.
Astarion steht in meinem Lager rum. Ich kenne ihn. Er ist nicht gerade der stille Typ. Ihr könnt- Okay. Verrate ich dem Typ, dass Astarion- Ich mag Astarion nicht, aber verpetzen will ich ihn auch nicht. Ja, mich mit den Leuten anlegen wegen Astarion will ich- Was will euer Stamm mit so einer Kreatur?
Dann frage ich ihn doch mal.
Kennt ihr ihn? Ja, ich kenne Astarion, aber ich will nicht, dass es Stress gibt. Ich kenne ihn, er ist nicht gerade der stille Typ.
Wollt ihr mir nicht verraten, wo er ist? Nein. Ich helfe euch nicht, ihn zu finden. Zurück.
Ja.
Dann fragen wir Astarion doch mal, ob er weiß, wo die Kinder von dem Typ sind. Aber vorher gehen wir aus dem Sumpf raus.
Leute, ich hab mal ne Frage an euch. Für alle, die das Spiel schon gespielt haben. Ich spoiler jetzt nicht, aber wart ihr auch überrascht, als ihr diese Scheune aufgemacht habt und die Cutscene, die dann gekommen ist?
Da hätte ich ja mit allem gerechnet, aber nicht mit dieser Cutscene.
Wobei, es ist kein Story-Spoiler. Dann will ich mal die anderen einweihen, was es für ne Cutscene gibt. Und zwar, wenn man diese Scheune aufmacht, sieht man, wie es zwei Ogre miteinander treiben.
Und Will sagt dann irgendwie sowas wie, ach das ist wie Ogre-Babys entstehen oder irgendwie sowas. Da hätte ich ja wirklich nicht mit gerechnet.
Okay, gehen wir nochmal ins Lager und fragen Astarion mal, was er zu den Kindern weiß.
Nein, ich will wissen, was mit den Kindern erinnert ist.
Okay, ich muss Story-Dialog führen.
Einfach euer Meister, sagt ihr. Mich interessiert nicht, was Astarion erzählt. Es geht mir voll am Arsch vorbei.
Astarion, deine Story interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich will keins davon sagen. Okay, machen wir es so.
Okay, jetzt kann ich ihn fragen, was mit den... Hier, ich habe im Sumpf einen Monsterjäger getroffen. Er sucht euch.
Er wollte euch fangen und zurück nach Baldur's Gate bringen. Er ist ein Gur, hat er das erzählt.
Ihr seid in Sicherheit...
Warum würden sie...
Natürlich würde er einen Gur schicken, um mich zu schlagen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wer sie sind.
Er weiß es nicht.
Dieser Schütze.
Cazador lässt mir wissen, dass sogar hier draußen...
Vielleicht will er eine Auszeichnung machen.
Oder vielleicht denkt er, dass Tod mir zu gut ist.
Ich bin gespannt.
Er könnte heute Abend in unser Camp gehen und dich töten.
Wir können wahrscheinlich eine Auszeichnung für Will machen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Warum sind wir hier?
Gut, dann...
Pennen wir mal eine Runde, würde ich sagen.
Weil... Sie sind alle am kotzen zur Zeit.
Ja.
Alle am kotzen.
Ich muss rasten.
Wow.
Was ist das hier?
Warum wählten das so viel aus?
Ja.
Three Head Auswahl Algorithmus.
Ah.
Gut. Alle wieder fit.
Wunderbar.
Weiter geht's.
Wieso brauchst du 80?
Äh... Entweder, weil ich auf Schwer spiele...
Oder weil ich so viele Gefährten mittlerweile im Lager habe.
Eins von beiden. Weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach, guck mal.
Da liegt noch was, was ich nicht gelootet habe.
Schweinelände.
Erstmal Schweinelände gelootet.
Und ein bisschen Gold. Perfekt.
Okay. Ähm... Und ich muss noch eine weitere Quest fertig machen.
Nämlich...
Die hier. Finde die verschollene Lieferung.
Und zwar...
ging's darum, irgend so ein paar Typen in so einem Untergrund... äh...
Dorf...
haben mich beauftragt, eine Karawane zu finden.
Hier hinten irgendwo.
Die eine geheime Kiste dabei haben.
Aber ich wollte die Karawane nicht umbringen.
Und deswegen habe ich die Kiste nicht mitgebracht.
Deswegen gehe ich jetzt da hin und gucke mal, was passiert.
Entweder...
werden die jetzt direkt feindlich und wollen mich killen.
Oder sie erzählen mir irgendwas darüber.
Keine Ahnung. Mal schauen.
Gucken wir mal.
Wahrscheinlich... Es gibt ja eigentlich nur zwei...
zwei Questausgänge bei den meisten Quests.
Entweder kriege ich eine Belohnung und die mögen mich.
Oder sie mögen mich nicht und wollen mich killen.
Und ich muss sie dann killen.
Das ist also die Standard-Quest-Ende.
In allen RPGs irgendwo.
Chat, wenn ihr auch gerade spielt, Frage an euch.
Was ist eure Lieblings-Party-Composition?
Also ich spiele die hier am liebsten.
Ich persönlich hätte anstatt Slayer Cell...
den Paladin lieber mitgenommen.
Aber der Paladin passt bei mir nicht in die Koop.
Von den Entscheidungen her.
Ich finde es halt immer noch doof,
dass es nur ein Vierer-Team gibt.
Ich finde ein Sechser-Squad wäre einfach so...
oder zumindest ein Fünfer-Team.
Ein Fünfer- oder ein Sechser-Team wäre einfach so...
so viel besser gewesen.
Du hast Kallak dabei. Okay.
Kann man auch machen.
Ich finde halt die... ich finde halt...
Barbarian ist übelst langweilig.
Rage und draufhauen.
Also...
Ich persönlich fände es besser,
hätten sie ein Fünfer-Party gemacht.
Oder sagen wir mal...
Oder sagen wir mal ein Sechser- oder Fünfer-Party.
Weil...
Also meine Logik dahinter ist eigentlich ganz...
ganz... denke ich ganz gut nachzuvollziehen.
Und zwar...
Vierer-Party...
kannst du einfach zu wenig...
Sag mal...
Mein Stream laggt doch manchmal.
Was ist denn hier mit Vodafone los?
Oder ist das einfach...
Ne, das ist glaube ich einfach nur mein Vorschaum-Monitor, oder?
Ich droppe keine Frames und nix.
Also meine Logik dahinter ist folgendes.
Du brauchst eigentlich immer einen Cleric.
Ohne Cleric kannst du nicht los.
Du brauchst immer einen Wizard oder ne... oder ne... ne...
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Hexenmeister?
Also du brauchst entweder eine Sorc oder einen Wizard.
Als... als Fullcaster. So.
Und einen Cleric.
Und du brauchst irgendeinen Frontliner.
Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip...
nur diese drei zur Auswahl.
Oder halt hier den... den Barbarian, wenn man spielen will.
Das heißt, im Prinzip bleibt...
Also die zwei Slots sind ja schon fest.
So, und wenn 50% Slots fest sind...
Und wenn ihr einen eigenen Charakter spielt...
Als Hauptchar... Ich spiele Gale... Gale als Main-Character.
Weil ich mir gedachte, den Wizard brauchst du eh.
Wenn ihr jetzt auch einen eigenen Charakter dabei habt,
dann habt ihr quasi drei Slots von vier schon fest.
Und ihr braucht noch einen Tank.
Das heißt, eigentlich ist kein Platz.
Fünf wäre okay.
Für fünf hätte man wunderbar Platz für einen eigenen Main-Charakter.
Oder vielleicht noch für ein bisschen so Utility-Kram.
So einen Bade dabei oder sowas zum Beispiel.
Aber vierer hast einfach zu wenig Space,
um ordentlich was reinzupacken außer das.
Das einzige, was in meiner Party...
Das einzige, was in meiner Party variabel ist,
ist theoretisch Will.
Und Will ist eigentlich auch zu wenig.
Er ist zu nice, um ihn rauszuschmeißen.
Anstelle von Will könnte man halt noch den Druide beispielsweise mitnehmen.
Oder noch einen zweiten Nahkämpfer oder irgendwas.
Also Will ist der Einzige, der variabel ist.
Aber so wirklich variabel ist Will auch nicht,
weil Will der Einzige ist, der hohen Charisma-Wert hat.
Deswegen hätte ich auch lieber den Paladin anstatt den Fighter mitgenommen.
Aber der Paladin passt halt einfach nicht in die Entscheidung rein.
Also ich... Eigentlich kann ich...
Ich kann nichts anderes spielen bis zum Ende des Games.
Cleric Wizard ist Pflicht.
Frontline ist Pflicht.
Gib nur den, weil der Paladin nicht bei mir reinpasst.
Und Will brauche ich für Charisma.
So. Also.
Deswegen ist Vierer-Party doof.
Fünfer-Party wäre viel, viel besser gewesen.
Ich meine, für mich persönlich wäre ein Sechser-Party optimal, ja?
Was für einen Charakter hattest du dir erstellt?
Gar keinen. Ich spiele Gale als Main-Character.
Also wenn ich... Du meinst... Okay.
Wenn es eine Fünfer-Party gegeben hätte,
dann hätte ich mir einen Sorc erstellt.
Hexen... Hexenmeister heißt es auf Deutsch, glaube ich, erstellt.
Kurzes Stück Pizza-Futter.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich mir keinen eigenen Charakter erstellt habe.
Weil ich halt denke, Wizard und Cleric ist Pflicht.
Frontline brauchst du eh.
Du hast eigentlich keinen Platz für einen eigenen Charakter.
Ich meine, das Spiel ist nicht schwer.
Ja? Ich meine, guck mal.
Das ist der höchste Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Die Fights, die ihr heute gesehen habt, waren alle easy as fuck.
Sogar die Hexe war dann schwer.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ja, genau. Das steckt alles nur an meinem High-IQ-Skill.
Ich meine, es hat einen gewissen Vorteil.
Ja? Muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Es hat schon einen gewissen Vorteil,
wenn man so ein bisschen die Grundsachen von D&D-Combat versteht.
Ja? Zum Beispiel das Debuffen mit Hex
und dann draufhauen, dass der Gegner vier bekommt und sowas.
Aber insgesamt muss man das nicht wirklich wissen.
Also es ist auch so nicht schwierig.
Zumal man jeden Fight irgendwie cheasen kann.
Zum Beispiel mit Fässern.
Mit explosiven Fässern und sowas.
Kann super krass cheasen.
Eigentlich fast alles.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was die sagen.
Die haben mich ja beauftragt.
Mach ich nicht.
Moment, da kann man Rüstungsfarben kaufen.
Okay, das ist mir sowas von wurscht.
Wo ist denn Zerus da?
Okay, ich habe ja ein bisschen Bedenken,
dass die mich killen wollen,
wenn ich ihnen sage, dass ich ihnen die Kiste nicht bringe.
Äh.
Was?
Wait a minute.
Moment, habe ich die Que-
Habe ich die Quest nicht richtig gelesen?
Oder ist das Game verbuggt?
Ich dachte meine Quest wäre gewesen,
die Kiste zurückzubringen.
Und ich habe die Kiste nicht zurückgebracht.
Ich dachte, die wollen mich jetzt killen.
Okay.
Auch gut.
In Ordnung.
Was habe ich denn bekommen?
Harold.
Harolds Verdammnis,
wenn du bei einem Ziel schaden wirst.
Ganz sauer.
Okay, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich habe zwar keinen...
...dedizierten Fernkämpfer.
Aber die freut sich da drüber.
Ab und zu.
Ich würde die ja gerne alle killen.
Und...
Und hier hinten looten gehen.
Aber das passt nicht so wirklich zu...
...zu den Charaktern, die einfach umzubringen.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, mach ich nicht.
Okay.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, mach ich nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, okay, ich lasse es gut sein.
Ich kill die nicht.
Weil mich...
Aber vielleicht können wir ja looten.
Vielleicht können wir ja looten.
Ohne, dass ich die alle umbringen muss.
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe doch Speak with Animals.
Isor, was geht?
Stone scent?
No stone sound.
Strange stone here.
The dark smells wrong.
Not night dark.
Around and around again.
Most it gets confused.
Das hat jetzt nicht so gelohnt mit denen zu reden.
Okay, du redest mit dem Hund.
Shadowheart, du redest mit dem NPC.
Hier, hier, hier, hier, hier.
Perfekt.
Nein, nein, nein, du redest mit dem NPC.
Und Gale, Gale knackt das Schloss.
What?
Du kannst...
Die sehen das einfach.
Na gut, komm, ich raub die nicht aus.
Ich lasse es einfach.
Ich würde sagen, dann gehen wir mal ins Underdark.
Wir könnten jetzt noch ein paar Sidequests machen hier.
Oder wir gehen ins Underdark.
Was meint ihr, Chat?
Also Underdark ist quasi ein Dungeon.
Ziemlich großer.
Wir können aber auch noch ein paar Sidequests hier oben machen.
Wobei, so viel habe ich eigentlich...
Was habe ich eigentlich noch für Sidequests hier oben?
Nichts mehr wirklich, ne?
Eigentlich nichts mehr.
Das Einzige habe ich das hier übrig.
Das ist aber glaube ich Main Story.
Das ist auch Main Story.
Bleibt eigentlich nur Underdark.
Wir gehen ins Underdark.
Wait a minute.
Wo sind wir?
Wir gehen ins Underdark.
Da war ich nämlich noch gar nicht großartig.
Da habe ich einen Wegpunkt freigeschaltet und das war es.
Wait a minute.
Warum bin ich eigentlich so dumm?
Ich habe doch sogar schon einen Wegpunkt.
Im Underdark.
Okay, Gale.
Passt.
Okay, eine Runde Light Casten, please.
Auf dich selbst, ja, okay.
Gale.
Eine Runde Light Casten, auch auf dich selbst.
Ja.
Schwert rausholen.
Let's go.
Fackel, Logbuch.
Boah, ist das groß, Alter.
Hier ist nichts.
Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe,
dann schießen mich diese Dinger ab.
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz testen,
ob ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ja.
Habe ich richtig in Erinnerung.
Das heißt, da kann ich nicht zum Tor raus.
Wie geht denn das jetzt am besten?
Runterspringen?
Oder gibt es was? Hebel!
Nee, das ist für das Tor.
Okay, die Energie kommt hierher.
Dann zerlegen wir die Statue mal.
Klingt nichts.
Aha.
Man kann den Stein bestimmt...
Nee?
Von hier vielleicht?
Ich denke mal, man muss den Stein kaputt machen,
dass diese Türme kaputt gehen.
Shadowheart ist inspiriert.
Wait a minute.
Warum ist Shadowheart inspiriert?
Zerstöre den Schutz der...
Ach so!
Ja klar, macht ja Sinn, dass Shadowheart inspiriert ist.
Shadowheart ist ja ein...
Steht das da irgendwo?
Ist ja ein Cleric von Sha.
Und Sha ist ja quasi der Erzfeind von Selune.
Oder Selune?
Selune?
Was auch immer, wie man die ausspricht.
Deswegen finde das natürlich Shadowheart extrem geil,
wenn ich Selune Tempel zerstöre.
Da geht richtig was ab.
Bei Shadowheart.
Uraltes Tagebuch.
Eigentlich muss ich diesen ganzen Kram nicht looten,
weil das eh nichts wert ist.
Kristall? Oh, oh, oh!
Es erdbebt.
Das muss ich...
Kann man das anklicken?
Hallo?
Nee, gibt keine Quest.
Jailor, moin!
Buckle.
Zermalmte Leiche.
Bucklebrau.
Oh, oh, was ist das da? Ein Minotaurus.
Oh shit.
Habt ihr gesehen, was das Ding für Level hat?
Wart ihr so schnell und habt es gesehen? Ich nicht.
Da müssen wir aufpassen.
Die Dinger können einen übelst schnell kaputt machen.
Was jetzt?
Natur fehlgeschlagen, Natur erfolgreich.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hund, komm da weg!
Level 4, ah, easy.
Der wird jetzt weg, der wird jetzt weggebashed.
Easy, easy bashen wird er jetzt.
Ich hab's nur für euch auf Deutsch gestellt,
weil die Leute es immer am liebsten in Deutsch sehen.
Okay, du gehst dahin.
Shadowheart, du gehst dahin.
ESL, du gehst auf jeden Fall zu Will vor.
Und Gail,
du
gehst dahin.
Und du gehst dahin.
Und du
gehst da rauf.
So, sehr gut.
Kann man nicht treffen, aber das Viech kommt ja gleich zu mir.
So, und Will wird den Typ jetzt
Eldricks blasen bis zum Mond.
Ja super, jetzt kann ich halt mit Gail nichts machen.
Okay, komm, wir verschwenden Fireball für das Viech.
Egal.
Zugwenden.
Ja, das ist jetzt blöde.
Das Viech kommt halt nicht an mich ran.
Komm, wir warten mal, was es macht.
Oh fuck, da sind ja noch mehr.
Das war jetzt vielleicht kein so cleverer Schachzug von mir.
Ölfers.
Nein!
Fucking shit, ey.
Nein, nein, nein.
Brauchst du einen Scheiß zu machen, ey.
Okay.
Ich hoffe,
wenn ich das Ding jetzt anschieße, hoffe ich, es trifft das Viech
und mich nicht.
Okay, vorher kriegt das Ding noch einen Knaufschlag in der Hoffnung, er ist betäubt.
Jawohl.
Ja, sehr schön, das hätte ich vorher machen sollen.
Mal ordentlich Damage machen.
Vielleicht.
Ah, nice.
Der greift mich jetzt nicht an.
Wobei, das bringt mir eigentlich gar nichts.
Das war ein dummer Zug von mir.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, müssen wir laden gleich oder nicht?
Mal gucken, ob ich den Abstand richtig getroffen habe.
Ich habe den Abstand nicht richtig getroffen.
Ich bin dead.
Keckel.
Ich habe mich selbst in die Luft gesprengt.
Game auf Deutsch oder Englisch?
Ich habe es nur für euch auf Deutsch gestellt.
Max, das war absolute Three-Head-Engagement.
Aber Leute, seht ihr, so schnell kann es gehen, wenn man nicht aufpasst.
Okay, vielleicht komme ich noch irgendwie aus der Sache raus.
Oh, Shadowheart ist komplett down?
Nee. Hä?
Oh, Shadowheart ist tot?
Nee, Shadowheart liegt nur.
Okay, wen brauchen wir jetzt eher?
Den Tank oder Will?
Ich nehme mal den Tank, weil ich vermute, Will ist danach gleich wieder tot.
Was? Ziel ist zu weit entfernt?
Ja. Kackbun.
Okay, und tschüss.
Ah, jawoll.
Okay, ich muss mich mal selbst heilen.
Und jetzt kann ich noch einen Heiltrank...
Heiltrank...
Werfen.
Ah, ich kann keinen werfen, weil ich erst aufgestanden bin.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was, glaube ich, so ein Baldur's Gate-Ding ist.
Dass du, nachdem du down warst, keine Action bekommst.
Oder braucht man die Action fürs Aufstehen?
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, wie das ist.
Ja, hoffen wir mal. Vielleicht haben wir Glück und ich überlebe es irgendwie.
Okay, Shadowheart am Start.
Okay, ich kann Will heilen.
Und Damage machen.
So, das muss jetzt ein Six-Head-Turn werden.
Also, ich werde auf jeden Fall schon mal als Bonus-Action Will heilen.
Ah, das war falsche Reihenfolge. Ich hätte das anders machen müssen.
Wobei, ich kann jetzt hier umswitchen.
Okay, Will, du verpisst dich mal ganz schnell.
Will, du misst die Steps.
Nee, du machst kein Mist.
Du haust einfach nur ab.
So, und Shadowheart muss jetzt den übelsten Six-Head-Move machen.
Alle anderen haben wir nix mehr.
Okay, wir können ihn noch Hex auf Wisdom.
Okay, das Ding ist noch verängstigt.
Der sollte mich nicht angreifen, solange er noch verängstigt ist, die Runde.
Das ist gut. Das ist gut.
Dann muss Shadowheart doch keinen Six-Head-Move machen, sondern...
Shadowheart versucht mal ein bisschen Ablenkung.
Abbildbeschwören. Lenke deine Gegner mit einer Illusion ab.
Gewähre einer...
Spiegelbilder.
Ich glaube, Shadowheart sollte gucken, dass sie überlebt.
Weil die machen übelst Damage.
Nee.
Ich versuche, das Viech abzuhalten.
Okay.
Hoffentlich klappt das.
Brege, Leute. Brege.
Okay.
Der soll den Hund killen.
Der Untere hat keine Reaction mehr übrig.
Weil ich sonst Schiss habe, dass der mich umchargt.
Sven, danke schön für den Sub.
Das Problem ist, dass ich mich nicht umcharge.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Das Problem ist, der Gegner brennt und brennt.
Damage könnte Fear removen.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube, so ist besser.
Der soll seine Action darauf verschwenden, den Hund zu killen.
Okay, Zug brennen.
Nice.
Er ist noch verängstigt.
What the?
Wie jetzt? Doch nicht?
Hä?
Oh.
Monka, ey.
Okay, der ist fast down.
Den kriegen wir vielleicht tot.
Habe ich noch irgendeinen Heiltrank mit der?
Ja, aber nur so einen Mini-Heiltrank.
Den kann ich mir auch gleich sparen.
Entweder machen die Damage und ich bin tot oder nicht.
Gut, ich habe eh Vorteil.
Okay, Damage machen.
Einfach nur...
Das macht ein bisschen mehr Damage.
Einfach nur Damage machen.
39, okay.
Ich könnte raus Misty steppen.
Das Problem ist nur,
das mache ich nicht, weil
dann ist er hier offen zu meiner Backline.
Das können wir nicht machen.
Okay, du musst Damage machen, Gale.
Du musst die wegballern.
Okay, Gale, Fireball.
Oder,
oder wir machen den Five-Head-Move.
Auf was geht denn?
Okay, Wisdom.
Der ist debuffed.
Der ist debuffed für
Weisheit.
Wie viel Wisdom haben die denn?
Warum haben wir nur Taurenhände und so hohe Wisdom-Saving?
Was ist das für ein Mist?
Warum sind die so weise?
Sie sehen irgendwie so weise aus.
Okay, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder
wir machen einfach Damage
und hoffen, alles wird gut.
Oder wir machen ein CC.
Das ist quasi so ein Betäubungszauber.
Wo die Gegner für zwei Züge nichts machen.
Dazu muss ich aber...
Also dazu dürfen die kein Wisdom-Saving-Throw gewinnen.
Der hier wird keinen gewinnen.
Oder höchstwahrscheinlich nicht, weil er debuffed ist mit minus zwei.
Aber er hat immer noch plus eins.
Komm, scheiß drauf, wir machen einfach Damage.
Wir machen einfach Damage.
Mit Damage kann man eigentlich nichts verkehrt machen.
26. So viel Damage war das jetzt aber nicht mal.
Sind die Feuer-resistant?
Nö.
War erstaunlich wenig Damage.
Okay, Will.
Will, du auch Fireball rein?
Will?
Äh.
Hä?
Will!
Du kannst einfach hier hinballern.
The fuck?
Will, was ist mit dir los?
Du kannst einfach hier hinballern.
So machst du es nicht so kompliziert, wie es sein muss.
Jawohl!
Erster down.
Und er hat ordentlich Damage gefressen.
Du-du-du.
Okay, mehr kann Will nicht machen.
Gail kann auch nichts mehr machen.
Shadowheart kann auch was machen.
Shadowheart
macht das, was Clerics am besten können.
Spirit Guardians.
Ist zwar ziemliche Verschwendung,
aber nach dem Fight muss ich eh rasten.
Ja, Spirit Guardians.
Spirit Guardians und Spiritual Weapon.
Okay.
Die macht jetzt-die macht jetzt einfach Damage.
Nice.
Ey, nicht abhauen.
Bam.
Ey, what?
Au!
Ey, die-die Dinger sind hart drauf, ey.
Okay, der hat noch 34.
34.
Okay, krieg ich den die Runde tot?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich krieg den die Runde tot.
Komm, wir-wir wasten den Fireball.
Und
wartet mal.
Shadowheart
belebt die wieder.
Wir machen erstmal
auf Ranger.
Das Problem ist,
wenn man die
Build-In, also die-die offiziellen
Companions reskillt,
dann passt die Story halt nicht mehr so wirklich.
Weil
ich mein,
du kannst Shadowheart auf jeden anderen
Cleric umspecken, solange
Sha die Domain erlaubt.
Dass es von der Story her noch passt.
Aber Ranger passt so gar nicht irgendwie.
Es sei denn, es ist einem egal,
ob die Companion-Story passt.
Dann kann man es natürlich umspecken,
wie man lustig ist, ja.
Okay.
Wir versuchen jetzt einfach mal
ordentlich Damage zu machen.
91%.
Easy.
91% Miss.
Nice. GG.
Sehr gut.
96%.
Na, kann ich jetzt auch mal vorbeihauen?
Okay, da haben wir sie noch.
Die kann nichts machen jetzt.
Will.
Okay.
Will
Eldritch Blaster
den Typ jetzt weg.
Und dann macht Gale
ihn mit Magic Missile platt,
weil Magic Missile kann ich missen.
Okay, Will one-shotte den Typ.
Auch gut. Nice.
Ey, so als kleiner Tipp, Leute.
Wenn ihr ein paar Gegner
oder einen Gegner habt,
den ihr sicher killen müsst
und ihr könnt euch kein Miss erlauben,
nehmt Magic Missile.
Magic Missile ist der einzige Zauber,
den es gibt
im gesamten Spiel
und im gesamten
Dungeons & Dragons-Regelwerk,
der nicht verfehlen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es ein guter,
quasi ein guter Einstiegszauber
sein soll.
Aber deswegen ist
Magic Missile irgendwie
immer noch
durch das ganze Game relevant.
Weil du damit wunderbar
Gegner finishen kannst.
Es sei denn, sie haben Schild.
Aber die wenigsten
Gegner, die nicht gerade
Caster sind, haben Schild.
Gewährt Resistenz
gegen Hiebschaden.
Gewährt Verwundbarkeit
durch Wuchtschaden.
Ne, das will ich nicht.
Geht kein Debuff.
Findest das Cleric
überhaupt nicht passend?
Ne.
Findest das Cleric
überhaupt nicht passt?
Naja.
Aber ihre Story
ist ganz klar,
dass sie halt
ein Cleric ist so.
Auch von der persönlichen
Companion-Story.
Aber wie gesagt,
das kann ja jeder spielen,
wie er will.
Und ich denke,
wenn man lieber einen Ranger
in der Party hat, okay.
Aber das ist halt so mein Ding.
Beim Respecken
von den offiziellen
Companions,
dann passt halt die
persönliche Story
nicht mehr dazu.
Find ich jetzt ein bisschen,
find ich halt ein bisschen doof.
So, können wir noch
weitermachen.
Ich meine, wir können noch
eine Short Rest machen.
Und ja,
wir haben eigentlich noch
genug Spells,
um weiterzumachen.
Gale kann noch
ein paar Spells
recovern.
Ja.
Perfekt.
Easy.
Ich hab nur ein paar
Cleric Spell Slots verloren.
Wir können weitermachen.
Leute, hört das?
Oh.
Gutschy Bass?
Für das,
dass ich den Anfang
des Fights so verkackt habe,
lief's dann doch noch
ganz brauchbar.
Dein Geist
angesichts der seltsamen
Stimme zur Ruhe bringen,
die Stimme ignorieren.
Sag mir,
dass ich mir diese Stimme
nicht nur einbilde.
Guter Punkt.
Mehr Gutschy Bass?
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt, jetzt,
irgendwas
ist am...
What the...
Was jetzt?
Aua.
War das gerade?
Hat das mir Damage gemacht?
Äh.
War das ein Landhai?
Machst du immer noch
die 4-Tage-Woche?
Ja, mach ich.
Abgrundgriecher.
Schurkenmorschl.
Wimmelpilz.
Ich, ich stelle
es mal ein bisschen.
Ich bin mir nicht
so ganz sicher,
ob man da...
Aber ja,
ich mache immer noch
4-Tage-Wochen.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
auch kein Interesse,
das jemals wieder zu ändern.
Hier sind so viele Pilze
am Start.
Ach komm,
genug Geschlecht, ne?
Oh.
Alter.
Eine Sprengmine.
Äh.
Crazy, mach doch.
Was...
Warum kannst du das nicht machen?
Was spricht bei dir dagegen?
Zu wenig Geld
oder zu wenig, ähm...
Unterstützung von der Arbeit?
Oder...
Was?
Warum kannst du es nicht machen?
Ich kann es nur jedem empfehlen.
Teilzeit ist einfach
das Beste, was es gibt.
Alter, ist wieder alles
fehlgeschlagen, Mann.
Brauch mal den Hund.
Der Hund.
Der Hund, der macht es jetzt.
Der Hund, er schnuppert.
Auf, Hund.
Schnupper.
Let's go.
Aha.
Schnupper, schnupper.
Ja, kann man da hochklettern?
Ach, kann man hochklettern?
Das ist der Fahrstuhl,
wo ich bei den anderen rauskomme.
Kann das sein?
Wait a minute.
Das ist der Fahrstuhl, gell?
Schauen wir mal.
Das sieht aus wie der Fahrstuhl,
wo ich...
Wo ich in dem...
Wo ich in der anderen...
Ja, das ist der Fahrstuhl.
Das ist der Fahrstuhl.
Weg freimachen hier.
Rustikale Truhe.
Gail.
Lass mal deine krassen
Lockpicking-Lawyer-Skills raus.
Easy.
Hoffentlich lohnt sich das.
Ah, Silberwaren.
Holz.
Der macht was mit Holster, Gail.
Ja, das ist der Fahrstuhl.
Das ist der Fahrstuhl.
Der macht was mit Holster, Gail.
Ah, hier war ich schon mal.
Kann ich nicht gewesen sein.
Es war alles voll.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich will nicht mit dir reden.
Nicht jetzt zumindest.
Was habe ich da gerade aufgesammelt?
Öl des Brandstifters.
Feuerresistenzen.
Hier ist aber viel, viel Loot am Start.
Und auch Sachen, die man gut verkaufen kann.
Pogge.
Kannst du mal anfragen.
Die können dir das nicht verbieten.
Natürlich kann ein Chef dir schon nahe legen.
So nach dem Motto.
Ey, das ist gerade bei uns ganz schlecht und so.
Aber die können dir das gar nicht untersagen.
Also wenn, wenn die dir das untersagen wollen,
können sie das eigentlich nur machen mit der Begründung.
So quasi.
Der Betrieb kann nicht aufrecht erhalten werden,
wenn jetzt der Crazy da in Teilzeit geht.
Aber selbst dann sind sie verpflichtet dazu,
der Sache Abhilfe zu schaffen.
Ja, das ist der Aufzug, wo wir,
wo wir hier runtergekommen wären.
Also wenn dir die Kohle reicht.
20% ist ja meistens halbwegs verkraftbar.
Wenn man jetzt nicht gerade eh schon auf dem letzten Loch pfeift.
Da kann ich das nur empfehlen.
Weil es ist ja nicht nur 3 Tage versus 4 Tage Arbeiten.
Also es ist ja nicht ein Tag mehr frei.
Es ist auch ein Tag weniger Arbeiten.
Verstehst du, wie ich meine?
Also es ist doppelt.
Du bist weniger geschafft dadurch,
dass es nur 4 Tage sind.
Und dann hast du noch einen Tag mehr frei.
Das ist doppelt von Vorteil.
Ein Tag weniger Arbeiten und ein Tag mehr frei.
Also ich kann es, ich wie gesagt,
ich kann es nur allen immer, immer ans Herz legen.
Sag mal, ist mein Light Spell irgendwie weg oder so?
Oder auch nicht.
So, wo geht es denn hier lang?
Hier oben auf dem Pilzstelzen mal runter gucken.
Boah, das ist ja riesengroß hier.
Übrigens, ich habe mir das Underdark so,
so Story-technisch eigentlich anders vorgestellt.
Also so wie ich mir das ausgemalt habe jetzt zu, zu,
also bevor ich das in Ballos Gate jetzt hier gesehen habe.
Eigentlich ist das Underdark,
sollte deutlich dunkler sein, als es das hier ist.
Ich verstehe aber, warum man das so gemacht hat.
Weil, naja, einfach, einfach komplexer,
einfach, einfach komplett dunkle Höhle,
ist halt optisch unschön.
Oh, guck mal, da ist ein Schwert am Start.
Einfach random steckt da ein Schwert drin.
Helm? Einfach so random ein Helm, äh, ein Schwert.
Stärke, das Hemd mit Beinen, Religion.
Dies kommt dir heilig vor.
Überlege, welches Ritual angemessen sein könnte.
Weggehen. Das macht Gale.
Gale, Gale ist da Historik, Historiker.
Hier, Gale hat Plan.
Religion plus 4.
High IQ Wizard.
15.
Oh.
Hey.
Erfolg.
Hm.
Etwas Blut auf den Stein tropfen lassen.
Kann man sich die, die Checks angucken und dann weggehen?
Das probiere ich mal kurz aus.
Nein, ne, das geht nicht. Shit.
Ja, wollte ich nur überprüfen.
Ähm.
Dann, dann gieße ich ein bisschen Blut drauf.
Man könnte, man könnte auch mal mit Stärke einfach dran ziehen.
Ja, das machen wir.
Wir ziehen mit Stärke dran und wenn das nicht klappt, können wir Blut drauf, drauf träufeln.
Aber das müssen wir mit einem anderen, äh ja, das müssen wir mit einem anderen Character machen hier.
Das muss sie machen, weil die hat 18 Stärke.
Da geht schon mehr ab.
Hab ich, hab ich irgendeinen Stärke-Drang oder Stärke-Buff oder irgendwas?
In der Richtung.
Glaube, ich hab sowas, wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege.
Vergrößern, verkleinern, Verwandlungszauber.
Ihre Würfe auf Stärke und ihre Rettungswürfe zu beeinflussen.
Okay, das brauchen wir.
Lernen.
Okay, geil.
Dann mach mal hier, äh, keine Ahnung, Netz weg.
Und vergrößern, verkleinern.
Übrigens normalerweise, das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich eigentlich gut finde, wie sie es in Baldur's Gate gemacht haben.
Normalerweise kannst du Sachen nur nach einer langen Rast neu vorbereiten und preparen mit dem Zauberbuch.
Das ist so die Dungeons & Dragons lite Variante, wie sie das hier in Baldur's Gate gemacht haben.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich find's gut, weil es hat keinen Sinn in dem Spiel, wenn man die Zauber wechseln will, einfach rasten zu müssen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite macht's dann wiederum keinen Sinn, warum es ein Zauberbuch gibt.
Wenn man die eh jederzeit ändern kann.
Okay, im Fight. Ja, okay, das ist das Einzige.
Dann machen wir das doch jetzt mal.
Dann vergrößern wir mal.
Vergrößern.
Und jetzt gibt's die Vergrößerte.
Und die darf da jetzt mal dran ziehen.
Stärke.
Plus 4 St-
Und vergrößert gibt Advantage.
Nice, okay.
Das können wir ja kaum noch fehlschlagen.
Guck mal.
Wir haben.
Okay, und jetzt.
Und, okay.
Wir kriegen noch.
Göttliche Führung.
Elixier der Hügelriesenster-
Nee, das, das geben wir jetzt nicht dafür aus.
Wie viel haben wir?
Wir haben plus 5 bis 8.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt mindestens eine 10 rollen, dass wir es sicher haben.
Kommt scheiß drauf.
Hauen wir auch noch drauf.
Okay, mindestens, mindestens ne 9 und das mit Advantage.
Das kann doch eigentlich.
Was ist das für ne Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir es schaffen?
90% oder sowas, hä?
Easy, geschafft.
Nice, neues Schwert.
Porg.
Warum ist das Schwert schlechter als das, was ich schon habe?
Ha, was ist das?
Can't wait.
Hey, was soll denn das?
Der Spell, was hat es denn für ne Chance?
Ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht.
Der Spell, was hat es denn für ein Spell?
Fala aluwe.
Melodie.
Das Schwert summt erwartungsvoll bereit, in unerträglichen Kreischen oder stärkende Gesänge auszubrechen.
Ja und wie?
Was soll das jetzt machen?
Das ist ja mal komplett wir beschrieben.
Okay, müssen wir mal Wiki gucken.
Ach Moment, ist das ein einhändiges Schwert?
Ach so, deswegen ist das schwächer.
Das ist ein einhänder Schild.
Super, ich habe kein Schild dabei.
7 bis 16, beidhändig.
Ansonsten 1d10.
Trotzdem nicht verkehrt.
Also ganz ehrlich, die Optionen halte ich mir immer offen mit nem Schild.
Weil manchmal brauchst du einfach ein bisschen mehr Armor Class.
Man sieht, wie viel das hier ausmacht mit dem Schild.
Die hat einfach 19 und mein Tank hat eigentlich nur 17.
Ja, das ist ein gutes Einhänder Ding.
Übrigens, es wäre auch cool gewesen, hätten sie noch einen zweiten Waffenslot gemacht,
dass man einfacher dazwischen umschalten kann zwischen zweihändig und einhändig.
Das wäre sehr cool gewesen.
Was haben wir denn? Kann die noch irgendwas anziehen?
Wenn der Träger das, habe ich nicht.
Kette des Bestienmeisters.
Tierfreundschaft brauche ich auch nicht.
Gewehrtresistenz, ne.
Okay, Todesstrength, dann stirbt sie nicht so leicht.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich mal ein Schild aus dem Lager mit, wenn wir wieder da sind.
Und dann kann ich zur Not hier auch einhändig mit Schild und einem ordentlichen Einhänder Langschwert spielen,
falls ich mal ein bisschen mehr Armor Class brauche.
Ich glaube, es wird Zeit gleich nach dem nächsten Fight für eine kurze Rast.
Beilspeer.
Moment.
Holzschild, haben wir doch. Passt doch.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ups.
Das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht.
Jetzt haben wir auch 19 Armor Class.
Okay, jetzt können wir uns entscheiden immer, ob wir Damage wollen,
oder ob wir Einhand-Tanky ein bisschen mehr wollen.
Ja, lau lau.
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Komme ich dann an der gleichen Stelle wieder raus, oder muss ich über...
...nur zum nächsten Teleporter?
Ich komme an der gleichen Stelle wieder raus? Okay.
Aber ich habe eh kein besseres Schild als das.
Hier waren wir schon.
Was?
Ach, das Ding.
Dann machen wir es einfach kaputt.
Bam.
Jetzt schreckt Pilz.
Der Hund wäre wieder fast gestorben.
Der ist auch ein bisschen lebensmüde.
Oh, automatische Speichern. Immer schlechter Hinweis.
Aua.
Au.
Oh.
Ein Landhai.
Hai-Stilz.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie tanky die ist.
Mit One-Hand und Shield.
19 AC ist wirklich ganz gut für Low-Level.
Ich frage mich, wann es die erste Plate-Armor gibt, weil dann müsste ich 21 AC haben.
Oh, Verteidigung, Waffenverzauberung.
Was gibt es denn hier Schönes?
Wo kann ich denn das auswählen, dass das mein Schwert so einen Zauber macht?
Oder passiert das automatisch? Das muss ich gar nicht casten.
Ne, hier ist es doch.
Das Schwert summt erwartungsvoll bereit in unerträglichkeit.
Okay, was macht das nochmal?
It's a Singing Sword.
Once per shot rest.
For an action you can turn on the singing for one of two modes.
Sing all allies within six meter gain plus four attack on.
Okay.
All enemies in six meter gain plus four attack on.
All enemies are on safes and take additional damage when hit.
Ach hier.
Okay, das ist eigentlich mega nice.
Das ist mega Pog.
Okay, Shadowheart, dann geh mal auf sechs Meter ran hier an das Viech, dass du den Buff abkriegst.
Aber vorher gibst du uns noch Bless.
Bless?
Bless oder Spirit Guardians?
Bless.
Ich glaube da braucht man Melee Damage auf dem Viech.
AWS, CDK oder Terraform?
Terraform.
Terraform Skills bist du unabhängig.
Okay, Bless.
Spirit Weapon.
So, Shadowheart, geh mal ran.
Dann darfst du jetzt singen, Schwert.
Und zwar Angriffswürfe, Charisma, Intelligenz und Weisheitsrettungswürfe.
Nice, sehr cool.
Und jetzt aufs Maul.
Boah.
Nice, und es blutet.
Pogu.
Zug beenden.
Gale.
Was kannst du machen, um das Viech zu killen?
Haste.
Gale, weißt du was?
Du machst es jetzt mal passiv.
Du gibst der Haste.
Du gibst...
Ja, du gibst der Haste.
Und jetzt geht's ab.
Moment, ich dachte ich krieg...
Ach, ich noob.
Ich hab den Zug schon beendet, das war dumm.
Ich hätte Haste...
Ich hätte Haste geben müssen, bevor ich den Zug beende, da ich nochmal draufhauen kann.
Ja gut, ich meine, da kann sie nächste Runde doppelt draufhauen.
Jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, dass sie nicht stirbt.
Das wäre jetzt nämlich enorm unvorteilhaft, wenn sie stirbt.
Heilung.
Drang der mächtigen Heilung, perfekt.
Werfen auf sie hier.
Fehlschlag?
Okay.
So.
Und Will?
Hau einfach mal ab, okay?
Sehr schön.
Der kann nix mehr machen.
Der Hund kommt vielleicht dran?
Nee, nicht ganz.
Du wolltest mich das fragen, du kannst mich auch ruhig noch mehr fragen.
Also wie gesagt, ich würde immer zu Terraform tendieren, weil damit kommt man einfach weiter, auch überall bei anderen Cloud-Anbietern.
Und Terraform-Skills sind deutlich mehr gesucht als AWS-CDK.
Übrigens, es muss gar nicht AWS-CDK sein.
Terraform hat genau sowas jetzt.
Auch sowas.
Such mal nach Terraform-CDK.
Die haben jetzt auch sowas.
Das ist glaube ich die beste Kombination dann aus beidem.
Habe ich aber selbst noch nicht benutzt.
Okay.
Fertig.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was das Viech macht.
Erstmal laggt es anscheinend.
Hallo?
Ich glaube, ich habe das Viech verbuggt.
Guck mal, es macht nix mehr.
Es ist kaputt.
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Okay.
Sleepge.
Bedge macht das.
Boah, wie viel AC hat denn das Ding?
Geht doch eigentlich.
17, ich habe ordentlich einen Bonus.
Okay, geil.
Und jetzt gibst du dem Ding abcastet.
Oh, 55 nur.
Ja, geil.
Was kannst du machen gegen das Viech?
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Geil.
Gib ihm einfach drei Magic Missiles und gutes.
Scheiß drauf.
Next.
So, der Hund kann drauf.
Nice, Damage.
Okay, Will macht noch keinen Bonus.
Okay, Will macht noch keinen Eldricks Blast.
Kann man Armor Class irgendwie debuffen?
Nein, geht nicht.
Dann hebe ich mir das nochmal auf.
Dann machen wir jetzt erstmal Massive Damage.
Mit Nahkampf.
Krass, Alter, vier Attacken.
LOL.
Die geht gut ab.
Mit Haste.
So, jetzt kann Will das Viech Eldricks Blasten.
Vorher debuffen wir es.
Für...
Oh, fuck, ich habe das Falsche angeklickt.
Oh.
Falsches Icon.
Ich wollte dem Ding eigentlich ein Hex geben.
Na gut, kann ich aber noch machen.
Ja, verklickt.
Ich wollte das Hex, sondern Eldricks Blasten.
So, jetzt kriegt das...
Okay, wir versuchen, Damage zu machen.
Sehr schön.
Und, ja, Will können wir heilen.
Wie gesagt, heilen ist eigentlich immer blöde mit dem Clary.
Nur wenn Leute down gehen, ist das gut.
Sag mal, ich glaube...
Ich glaube, ich habe es echt verbuggt, oder?
Ich glaube, der macht Badge.
Okay, dann mache ich jetzt einfach nichts mehr und gewinne easy.
Weil das Viech verbuggt ist.
Auch gut.
Dann...
Ja, es ist verbuggt.
Ich muss danach eh rasten.
Ich kann jetzt auch alle Spells raushauen.
Krass, wie es verbuggt ist.
Also mit Haste geht die ja mal richtig durch hier.
Keckel.
So, und jetzt Eldricks Blast.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mit dem Game gemacht habe,
aber die KI war etwas überfordert gerade.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Blutlutscher.
Kleidung.
Das ist was für Barbarians oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Und eine Schaufel.
Okay.
Ich muss rasten.
Keine Shortdress, ich brauche eine lange Rast.
940 von 80.
Ich glaube, ich kann es mir erlauben.
Genug Vorräte.
Das ist auch mega cool, oder?
Guckt mal, Leute.
Die haben das Lager immer angepasst an die Umgebung, wo man gerade ist.
Vorher waren wir oben im Wald, also war mein Lager auch im Wald.
Jetzt sind wir unterirdisch im Underdark, also ist mein Lager auch da.
So als hat man richtig das Lager dort gebaut.
Also mega immersive.
Das haben sie cool gemacht.
Um nicht zu sagen, Hogu.
Was, langer Lachs?
Will doch irgendjemand mit mir reden im Lager?
Naja.
Keiner.
Was?
Warum ist die Autoauswahl so pepega?
Ja, okay.
Bädge.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen macht er jetzt.
Oh, ich muss mit Scratch reden.
Besser.
Speak with animals.
Scratch hat mal wieder Geld gefunden.
Was hast du denn da, Kratzer?
Vielleicht kannst du es mir sagen.
Alles was ich weiß ist, dass ich an dich gedacht habe, als ich es sah.
Heiltrank.
Ja, jetzt wird er gepettet.
Fein Heiltrank gebracht.
Exzellent.
Dann gehen wir mal aus dem Lager raus.
Will wieder vorne hin.
Dann Licht.
Licht.
Sehr schön.
Gut, wie geht es weiter?
Wo ist mein Imp?
Moment.
Moment, der steht noch im Hexenhaus rum.
Den habe ich ja komplett vergessen.
Den habe ich ja komplett vergessen, den Imp, Alter.
Okay.
Beschwörung aufgeben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Irgendwas hat doch gefehlt, ne?
Können wir mal neu rufen.
Teufelchen nennt sich das also auf Deutsch, okay.
Gut, was gibt es denn hier schönes?
Können wir rüber springen?
Und Fackelstelz.
Das heißt nicht wirklich so, oder?
Fackelstelz.
Bester Name.
Hat sich ausgestelzt.
Okay, Fackelstelz.
Da müssen wir aufpassen.
Das müssen wir immer aus sicherer Entfernung alles wegnuken.
Ich werde das mal kurz.
Ich werde das mal kurz mit Will alles wegfackelstelzen.
So, ich glaube, da hinten ist noch.
Oh, nicht da reingehen, Will.
Hier hinten ist auch noch was.
Okay.
Fackelstelz.
Hier hinten ist auch noch Fackelstelz.
Oh, was ist das da oben?
Oh, das sind Gätschners.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Giftiger Mykonide.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie die The Last of Us Monster.
Sporendiener Mykonide.
Gut.
Jetzt zeige ich euch nochmal, warum der Imp wirklich Pogu ist.
Der Imp ist nämlich ein mega geiler Kundschafter.
Jetzt ist er unsichtbar.
Schriftrolle, Rucksack.
Jetzt können wir nämlich hier oben langfliegen.
Guck, und die checken das nicht.
Da hinten sind noch mehr. Okay, okay.
Hm.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher.
Sind das Gegner?
Oder kann ich mit denen reden?
Ehrlich gesagt sehen die nicht sonderlich gesprächig aus.
Man weiß ja nie.
Also, warum ich mir da Gedanken mache ist,
entweder
Stealth nuke ich die jetzt mit einem Fireball weg,
oder ich kann mit denen reden.
Ich wäre ja für mit Fireball weg nuken.
Da können sie nicht viel machen.
Die kriegen einen doppelten Fireball ab.
Da sind die fast zur Hälfte tot.
Chat, das könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Soll ich mit den Viechern reden und gucken, was sie zu sagen?
Okay, macht erstmal diplomatisch. Na gut.
Okay, speichern wir mal.
Ich hoffe, das geht nicht kaputt, wenn ich da...
Shit.
Jetzt raste da aus.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Jetzt drehen sie durch.
Kecke.
Ich hätte es doch einfach in die Luft sprengen sollen.
Aber hat ja nicht viel Damage gegeben.
Die Viecher singen viele Stimmen.
Die Harmonie eines gesamten Kollektivs.
Sovereign.
Er ist gekommen.
Er ist hier.
Der Chor weht.
Eine einzige Melodie steigt über die anderen.
Rassistisch und beobachtend.
Ich bin Sovereign.
Schön für dich.
Dein lebendiges Körper, verpackt in funkelnden Tendrils.
Der Sovereign bedroht dich.
State your purpose.
Sie können eigentlich gar nicht versagen, außer mit einer Eins.
Weave through your mind.
Seeking your true intent.
Then the Sovereign drones a new melody.
Cautious, but welcoming.
Descend to me.
Let us speak in flesh.
The persistent music coaxes you forward.
The Sovereign expects you.
Er ist gekommen.
Die Viecher singen viele Stimmen.
Die Harmonie eines gesamten Kollektivs.
Der Chor weht.
Der Sovereign bedroht dich.
Er ist gekommen.
Der Chor weht.
Der Sovereign dreht sich.
Okay, mit dem kann ich gar nicht reden.
Okay, ich muss zum König.
Bettge?
Okay, jaja, ich geh zum König, ist okay.
Ah, ein Schnellreisepunkt. Pogu.
König ist bestimmt hier oben, ha?
Was ist das da?
Ja, das da oben ist der König.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht wieder runterhüpfen!
Hier, hoch!
Die stellen sich manchmal mit.
Die Wegfindung ist teilweise echt hartkopfhüpfig.
Egal.
Aufs Kletsch.
Ah, es kommt jetzt.
Naja.
Die ist immer so aggressiv drauf.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich hab's jetzt vielleicht nicht so unbedingt mit Zwergen.
Aber Zwerge sind mir immer noch lieber als
diese Viecher da.
Was habt ihr mit der Leiche gemacht?
Die können sich ja eh nicht ab.
Ehrlich gesagt
will ich nicht
hier großartig
Alley machen mit den
Viechern.
Ich guck mal schnell,
ob die irgendeinen Händler haben.
Wo es vielleicht irgendwelche coolen Sachen gibt.
Weil wenn ich die nicht
kille, kann ich noch nicht mal looten.
Und ich muss alles looten.
Immer.
Drehen sie wieder durch, weil sie Pilzsporen
eingeatmet haben.
Händler!
Ein Händler.
Okay, okay, passt mal auf.
Jetzt,
jetzt lenken wir den Händler ab.
Mit Will.
Ah, der hat auch so ein Viech.
Gut.
Will redet mit dem Typ.
Dann geht Gail jetzt her.
Wait a minute.
Perfekt.
Und Gail knackt jetzt,
knackt jetzt die Truhe von ihm.
Oh, fuck.
20er Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Okay, nochmal.
Hey!
Moment.
Ich hab erst ne
1 gewürfelt und jetzt ne
20?
Ja, geil. Das musste er auch erst mal schaffen
hintereinander.
So geil ist es jetzt nicht, dass ich das gelohnt hätte.
Aber der Händler hat nichts mitgekriegt.
Habt ihr was
Interessantes zum Handeln?
Okay, was hat denn der Typ?
Stiefel des Wohltunenschreitens.
Die Bewegungsrate des
Trägers wird durch schwieriges Gelände nicht beeinträchtigt.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht,
aber am besten, man läuft erst gar nicht darum,
wo schwieriges Gelände ist.
Diadem des Versenks. Oh!
Das ist gut.
Aber nur einmal.
Einmal pro lange
Rast ist halt dann...
Das ist ja im Prinzip ein Level 2 Spellslot
mehr. Das ist...
Ja...
Und das ist ein...
Was? Ein Kurzschwert.
Ich hab niemanden der Kurzschwert da benutzt.
Eissturm. Das brauch ich.
Hab ich noch nicht.
Level 3 oder Level 4 Spell?
Ich glaub...
Level 3. Das brauch ich
auf jeden Fall.
Lebensspender.
Schwaches Elementarbeschwören.
Das ist mega nice.
Summons sind generell immer
richtig gut.
Fliegen hab ich schon.
Das brauch ich.
Und ob ich Eissturm schon hab, weiß ich nicht.
Da muss ich mal kurz nachgucken.
Zauberbuch. Gail.
Ich hab beides noch nicht.
Fliegen hab ich.
Da würd ich doch sagen, will ich beides
haben. Okay.
Ich will Eissturm und ich
will Schwaches Elementarbeschwören
haben.
Was haben wir hier noch? Person festhalten.
Nebelstritt hab ich schon.
Schon.
Darts.
Der Rest interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so. Hexe hat keinen Zugriff
drauf. Das macht nichts. Aber Gail
kann einfach alles lernen.
Ja.
Kriegt er mal ein bisschen was zum Ausgleich.
Da kann man Tränke draus brauen.
Brauch ich nicht.
Auch nicht. Ich hab Speak with
Animal. Brauch ich nicht.
Wobei das ist glaub ich um gegnerische
Beasts, dass die einen nicht
angreifen. Brauch ich auch nicht.
Auch nicht.
Kann mein Cleric übrigens auch
den Zauber
ähm. Hab ich schon gelernt.
Brauch ich auch nicht.
Da kann man eine von verkaufen.
Behalt mal eine, falls Will das casten soll.
Spinnennetz
zerbersten. Ja, kann man alles bein...
Beine brauch ich nicht.
Das Bein von Chico verdeckt die
oberste Zeile.
Tatsächlich.
Viel besser. Was haben wir hier?
Wait a minute.
Du erhältst einen zusätzlichen
Zauberplatz des ersten Gra...
Das ist ja mega.
Ist das ein Trank
oder was? Das ist ja
Pog. Das ist, das ist gleich
das wird sich gleich Gale reinhauen.
Das wird sich gleich Gale reinpfeifen.
Okay, nice.
Aber fast alle
verwende ich auch nicht.
Schaufel, die brauch ich noch.
Verfaulte Karotte. Oh ja, das
möchte der bestimmt haben.
Verfaulter Fisch, beste.
Verfaulte Eier, beste.
Das verkaufe ich auch immer.
Okay, gut.
Hab ich eigentlich alles für ein Shit gesammelt, man?
Ich hab im Lager auch so viel noch.
Okay, komm, zack.
Rauschen.
Very well.
Neueste
die zwei Sachen.
Und wo war das, wo war der andere Trank,
den ich noch hatte? Hier.
Elixier der Arkankultivierung.
Ein zusätzlichen
Zauber des ersten Grades.
Ersetzt bei Konsum
die Effekte anderer Elixiere.
Wie jetzt?
Also man kann immer nur
eine Elixiersorte
oder wie aktiv haben oder was?
Hä, wie darf ich mir das vorstellen?
Das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Kann das Shadowheart
auch futtern?
Mir wäre, ganz ehrlich,
mir wäre ein Cleric-First-Level-Spell
sogar noch lieber
als ein Wizard-First-Level-Spell,
weil Cleric-First-Level-Spell
ist heilen
und heilen, wenn einer down gegangen ist,
kann man nie genug haben.
Na gut, wir können auch Heiltränke werfen.
Aber vorher
lernen wir erstmal die Spells.
Ja, okay.
Ah, das sind...
Das sind beides Level 4.
Okay, Level 4 kriege ich erst mit nächstem.
Mit nächstem Level.
Oh, ich brauche noch einiges XP
bis Level 6.
Ja, dann probieren wir das doch jetzt mal kurz aus.
Ob das was bringt hier.
Trinken.
Ja, cool!
Das ist permanent.
Ein permanenter
Einsatz-Spell-Slot.
Das ist doch mega nice.
Kann ich nichts sagen. Das ist Pog.
Das nehme ich.
Das nehme ich mit.
Will bringt das leider nichts.
Wobei, das müsste man mal auspumpen.
Ja, ist gut.
Das müsste man mal ausprobieren, weil
Will hat ja keine Level...
Also, Warlocks haben ja keine
Zauber-Level in dem Sinn.
Warlocks haben ja immer nur
maximale Stufen von Zaubern.
Dafür weniger Slots.
Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Was ich da täglich gemacht habe...
Oh, ich habe doch viele Videos
gemacht, was ich auf der Arbeit getrieben habe.
Auf YouTube gucken, jede Menge.
Und ich habe ganz unterschiedliche Sachen
gemacht. Okay, ich lade noch mal kurz.
Das will ich mal ausprobieren.
Ich will mal gucken, was passiert, wenn Will
diesen Drang schluckt.
Was passiert, wenn Will diesen Drang schluckt?
Ach, man kriegt...
Hä?
Warlocks können keine
Level-Spell-Slots haben.
Kann man Feinfamilie abcasten?
Geht das?
Nee, oder?
Das gibt es, glaube ich, nicht.
Das ist nicht so gedacht.
Ja.
Aber Will hat...
Ehrlich gesagt, ist es ziemlich sinnlos mit Will.
Will kann auf Level 1
nichts Gescheites hier...
Nee, das bringt nichts.
Gail soll das saufen und gut ist.
Es war schon sinnig, dass Gail
das trinkt. Ich meine, Shadowheart
wäre auch nicht schlecht gewesen, aber Gail...
Gail kann es ehrlich... Wizard braucht Spell-Slots.
Gibt eigentlich nichts Besseres.
Ich habe ganz viele unterschiedliche Sachen gemacht
als Deluxe-Admin.
Als ich bei der Bank war,
was anderes, als wo ich beim Provider
war, als beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
war ich noch viel manuell unterwegs
in unterschiedlichen Rechenzellen,
hab mir dort Sachen auch vor Ort angeguckt,
hab Surfer ein- und ausgebaut.
Also, ich habe alle möglichen Sachen schon gemacht.
Aber, wie gesagt, nur
im Lidungsumfeld. Von Windows habe ich keine Ahnung.
Naja, wie gesagt, ich weiß.
Soll ja auch Gail kriegen, dann.
Ey, Gail hat 5 Spell-Slots.
Das ist ja mega.
Leute, ich bin jetzt 4 Stunden online.
Mir reicht's. Ich wollte eigentlich
nur bis 18 Uhr spielen.
Ich hab euch ja erzählt, ich hab noch 2 Stunden Zeit.
Und jetzt ist es 20 Uhr.
Wie das halt so ist.
Übrigens, nicht wundern,
Baldur's Gate braucht richtig lange
zum Steam-Uploaden der Spielstände.
Der Spielstand
ist ja auch irgendwie 100 MB oder so groß.
Das ist ja riesig.
Das sind schon, keine Ahnung, 3 TB
Save-States.
Was macht eigentlich die Spielerzahl von Battle-Bit?
Das muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Battle-Bit-Steam-Charts.
Ja gut, das dachte ich mir.
Das ist das, was ich in meinem Video auch gesagt habe.
Würde mich wundern, wenn das so krass
oben bleibt. Aber, das macht ja nix.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, wie sich das fällt. Das war aber klar.
Okay, Leute.
4 Stunden am Stück Gaming-Zeug
habe ich ja wirklich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Spielst du noch Battle-Bit?
Habe ich eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt.
Heute Morgen habe ich schon
gespielt. Also muss man sagen,
Baldur's Gate 3 ist wirklich ein mega gutes Game geworden.
Bis auf die paar Kritikpunkte,
die ich ja auch die ganze Zeit
immer wieder erzähle, aber
insgesamt muss man echt sagen, das Spiel ist wirklich
sein Geld wert.
Und, was ich
cool finde, so im Hintergrund,
ich dachte nämlich eigentlich bisher
das Wizards of the Coast, also die
Dungeons and Dragons
und, was machen die noch?
Warhammer?
Nee, Warhammer ist, nee, das eine
ist Games Workshop und das andere ist
Wizards of the Coast. Was auch immer.
Was haben die sonst noch?
Magic haben die noch. Magic und
Zeug. Zumindest, ich dachte
bisher eigentlich immer, dass es so war,
dass Wizards of the Coast
zu Larian Studios gegangen ist
und hat gesagt, ey,
wir haben gesehen, eure letzten
RPGs waren mega, wollt ihr nicht
in Baldur's Gate 3 machen?
Nein, ist es nicht. Larian hat Geld
dafür bezahlt, dass sie Baldur's Gate
3 machen konnten.
Also es ist gar nicht so, wie man so denkt.
Wizards of the Coast hat
überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun gehabt, großartig, außer
ihnen die Rechte zu geben für den Namen
da dran. Es war keine
Auftragsarbeit in dem Sinn.
Die haben da schon alles so auf diese Karte
gesetzt und ich finde, das merkt man
den Spielern an. Da haben sie sich wirklich sehr, sehr viel Mühe gegeben.
Wenn ich
auch eine 5er oder 6er Party
noch mehr gefeiert hätte, sag ich euch ganz ehrlich,
4er Party ist einfach zu knapp.
Aber, ja, das ist natürlich
Meckern auf hohem Niveau bei dem Game.
Und es gibt wenig Games, wo ich
so viele Stunden am Stück noch spielen kann
und immer noch Bock drauf hab.
Das ist ein Game, was durchaus auch vor
15 Jahren hätte erscheinen können
und es gut in die Zeit gepasst hätte,
so von, wie man sich noch Mühe gegeben hat
beim Spiele entwickeln.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis denn.
See you.